there's no time
[Music]
13 o clock hello folks and Happy New
Year's Eve if you're watching this on
New Year's Eve if you're a patron you're
watching it on New Year's Eve EU yeah I
don't know what we're really gonna be
doing on New Year's Eve
probably nothing a lot of money is
Christmas we really did I know I got an
extension on the damn credit card I
burned it the [ __ ] up you did yeah yeah
I know it's kind of sucks but it's like
well it's I don't know it's kind of like
I kind of like going out New Year's Eve
cuz I like going out you know for like a
holiday and everything like that but
then in a way to it seems like I don't
know it's kind of amateur night kind of
like going out on st. Patrick's Day when
everybody that doesn't usually it's not
all the season drinkers like ourselves
it's like just like riding a bike week
in Daytona Bike Week when you live here
you're like man [ __ ] you where those
people come from yeah because normally
you know if we're if you ride like we do
around here you're the center of
attention you live here yeah you know I
mean you don't need all these foreign
bikers and [ __ ] foreign bikers are on
other parts of the state and other
states coming over here cramping our
style with their motorcycles you know
what I mean it's like Daytona was way
worse because it's like although like I
said I didn't I didn't really my bike
weekend biked ever Biketoberfest as much
as I minded Spring Break because I used
to live over in the beachside
oh man - that was horrible it was like
hundreds and hundreds of thousands of
like drunken frat boys and sorority
girls yeah barfing in the yard and yeah
so today's show is gonna be about Lizzie
Borden Lizzie Borden it's like something
flies encase requested this a while back
and I was like oh yeah yeah man that was
like a really good idea and I don't
no I don't even think this was on my
list even though this is one of my
favorite cases you would think that we
had done this case all right I know
that's what I mean and it just seemed
like a drastic oversight so we're
finally getting around to doing it it's
kind of a pedestrian case I mean that
you think that everybody knows this case
I mean I've you know maybe not I mean if
not if you're yes it's like probably
what the most famous case or one of the
most famous case from the u.s. at least
in the nineteenth century but you know
maybe people that live in other
countries don't know that much about it
don't want to hear arc tank or they just
want to hear our take on it or something
like that I mean I found this really
interesting I read like a whole book on
it I've read like a whole bunch of I
seem like a whole bunch of documentaries
and [ __ ] like that I will say you know
this is technically considered an
unsolved case because I don't know if
people are aware but Lizzie Borden was
actually acquitted of the murders of her
mother of her father and stepmother but
um I don't know it seems like opinions
kind of divided whether she really did
or whether it was somebody else I kind
of tend toward her doing it although
there are some kind of details of the
case that kind of gives me pause but if
you put a gun to my head and said who do
you think did it I think she probably
did it why you did - but they've made
like a whole bunch of movies about it
and everything like that I think they
had what there was one with Christina
Ricci there was one I think it was back
in the 70s or 80s with Elizabeth
Montgomery your favorite yeah I think
she played Lizzie Borden I think we
might have been a TV movie yeah I think
it's on YouTube for free I need to watch
that [ __ ] I think I thought a long time
ago but I don't remember much about it
before I forget I'm working on the
shirts right now yeah
cozy $20 and up patrons yeah cut a
screen guts got the fabric mounted got
the emulsion on there it's still dry and
I went checked it it's it's got a couple
little wet socks I'm attackee yeah yeah
but we might be we might be able to
actually make the image tonight after
the show yeah we'll see well yeah the
night time I wanted to do it when it's
dark yeah it's like I have the
transparency made in place for the thing
we just haven't like asked I say yes you
guys don't know what I'm talking about
it's gonna be a black shirt kinda like
the one I have now
black-and-white and it's gonna say 13
o'clock podcast on it but it's done in
the font and the style of a Friday the
13th one part one the Friday when that
big 13 comes busting through the glass
Jim did a good job on it so thank you
it's gonna be like that I like my take
on this it's a mash up shirt and from in
here on out I think our show shirts
really I should make some cool mashup
shirts that's actually a really good
idea it's like I was thinking about
maybe doing a shining one yeah I was
thinking about doing I don't know yeah
shining alien [ __ ] you know predator
that would be rad uh I would mind doing
a predator one or a terminator one that
would also be cool yeah with a punk-rock
Arnold with his second two weapons
[ __ ] shooting up to them yes I mean
like I said use it for copyright issues
you can't like yeah but I have to
combine the two it has to mash-up yeah I
mean if you're just making them for
patrons to send out I don't think
there's a price and we can do whatever
we want to it's just ones that we're
gonna put up for sale that you can't use
yes like that because I mean the third
the the one that I did this time that's
Friday the 13th
basically all I used from that was like
the font and like the style of the
poster like the kind of 3d letters some
people you know on prior shows have
asked us yeah I want that shirt how much
we'll get back to you in a bit we're
gonna do the mail out first and once the
mail outs done then we're worried about
customers that people that want to buy
the shirt yeah it's probably gonna be a
twenty dollar shirt and you had to pay
the shipping if you live in another
country
we might be able to work something out
because I don't think it's reasonable
and [ __ ] for you paying what the hell
damn bog killing that was some yagi [ __ ]
they're a little moth got him oh that's
cuz I know the door looking for the cat
but what I was gonna say is I don't
really think it's reasonable charging
250 dollars for a damn shirt well no
that's obviously yeah maybe we can work
something out if you live overseas and
it you know maybe they can give you a
little bit of price break on it yeah the
shipping is not yeah the shipping is
expensive but and it's not that
expensive but you know I've mailed some
stuff overseas like to Ireland Australia
and stuff like that and it actually
wasn't as yeah expensive but as I was
expecting with with us shipping you
probably had about about another $70 on
it right I don't even know if it would
be that large because it's you still
have to ship it as a package I think
when I ship them as packages before I
think this postage I don't being between
like five and six dollars okay so look
at 25 bucks for the shirt yeah and it'll
be to whatever size you want handcrafted
by me using a photo screen yeah you know
I'm doing photo screen so and they come
out good the quality is really good
I used the best of quality best quality
materials that it wants that image is on
there it stays same if you want to
darken that shirt back up they're gonna
have a lot of cotton sprite it's mostly
cotton yeah it'll be a blend but real
heavy in the cotton so that means if it
starts to fade you could hit it with RIT
that you can get it RIT died yeah at you
get the supermarket and keep it black
and it won't affect the image also I'd
like to give another thank you to Mary
for recommending Jiffy shirts calm yes
that's what we used it because that's
what we use this time at it's like you
know that not only are the price is
really reasonable but they sent it like
immediately I got it like yeah it's like
a day and a half after I worded this
[ __ ] I got out shout out to GT shirts
and during the Christmas season right so
you know that right so that's I'm not
worried about getting everybody's order
right now if you want one after we've
done the mail out I'll hit you guys back
up again we'll make up a list and we'll
order some more yeah cuz that's a yeah
we're just gonna take em in in batches
right all right another thing I want to
say if you enjoy the show please support
us on patreon we could use some more
patrons you know of course we have we
have a real hardcore following the
patrons a lot of them pay us a lot of
money but we have a big show now so if
there we have enough people to listen in
that every dollar would now help so if
you guys wanna you know if you want the
show to continue please contribute a
dollar or so patreon that'd really help
us out
yeah and it'll make sure it'll guarantee
that the show keeps on moving we are
almost to 8,000 subscribers we're almost
8,000 and I don't know how many people
listen on I think my Tunes or other
podcasts we have no idea I just put the
[ __ ] up and like they're on the podcast
please contribute if you can also a
dollar
a month on patreon patreon would would
help now and yeah you know the aperture
so yeah it's all I gotta say about I
mean speaking of patreon I would also
like to give a shout out to Kali for
increasing her patreon support supported
before but has increased her support so
thank you very much Holly have a couple
of other shout outs um I would like to
thank our fan out of time pictures for
sending us a movie called looker which I
don't think I had ever seen now you
think I saw in it it was like a wit was
working reading by Michael Crichton
we're gonna do a review on it yeah it'll
probably be a couple of weeks cuz I
think we're gonna do another I had this
one confused with the Tom Selleck movie
run away run away that was also written
by Michael Crichton right because I
remember that they were trying to shoot
each other with a damn gun that would
mesmerise you using light and you know
Michael Crichton he wrote some [ __ ]
trip [ __ ] and I liked his other movies
like Deaton seed I really liked that one
yeah he well he did west west world and
they get him dramatist rain too didn't
he
uh he might have I might have to check
but obviously he wrote Jurassic Park is
old yeah I was thinking it was either
Andromeda Strain or coma whatever says
pried it down was it one of those I'd
like to see anything more that from this
guy if you guys want to hear more
Michael Crichton style reviews send the
[ __ ] to us I'll review it yeah because I
don't think I had ever seen this movie
and I found it very intriguing yeah
movie was kind of ahead of its time in
its own way it was kind of we'll do it
we'll do a review yeah it's like it'd
probably be a couple weeks like I said
cuz I I have one oh you get it that you
were good again you didn't get it got up
off the floor oh I caught him now he
can't be resurrected put him outside oh
don't you suck yeah I can't believe you
killed on him a little bit
you stepped on him a little bit yeah I
just stepped on a little bit
you're terrible I guess I don't have
time to you know maybe cuddle these
moths and [ __ ] I know you're not talking
bout Mothra I that was just a little bit
you know I hit those things on my
motorcycle all the time just killed me
just vaporize you know just by accident
so if he was a big old sphinx moths
maybe I'd have taken him out but small
so yeah it's a robot moth so yeah and
also I meant to mention this on our
matinee show on Sunday because I was
actually wearing the shirt on that show
but I would like to give another shout
out to Sophie and like I said she sent
me that like really awesome book that
Ian Brady the Mohr's murderer wrote and
I'm a little more than halfway through
that book and it's fascinating yeah but
she also sent me and I think it was hers
also sent me a really cool t-shirt which
like I said I'm wearing it in the
matinee show from Sunday yeah so thank
you very much yeah she sent me a bottle
of some badass tequila called 14:14
there's some hand crabs you're pretty
bottle yeah handcrafted designer [ __ ] he
romantic you know it's like a 60 $70
bottle so if he's so awesome she always
like sends us like really cool I was
drinking it it kind of had this
something and this is his back taste I
could taste the cinnamon and vanilla
that's real common in tequila but there
was like ass back no it was kind of hot
eat heat you're not I mean so what is
that it was good get up yeah you're
becoming a real yeah and it was habanero
and white pepper that's right up your
ass yeah I tried some of it on the rocks
it was good then I put a splash of damn
um citrus in it you know orange juice
and it got even better but that one's
too high quality to do with what I
normally do you know like mix it with
gridlock and [ __ ] yeah that's my that's
my cheap that's your buddy all day thank
you you know what awaits the good
tequila yeah I don't want to waste the
only stuff oh I get it
yeah yeah I haven't tried I haven't
tried 14:14 with that guava juice guava
nectar
it might work with it probably see why
not yeah you can't water it that you
can't water it down you got to leave it
strong it likes to be mixed strong
14:40 likes that
strength strength yeah
Jenny spotlight in my idiosyncrasies
oddities well I think they're pretty
obvious to everyone it's like I don't
think I really need to be that - at me
well you know no one's laughing at you
laughing oh they say all kinds of
[ __ ] funny laughing are you laughing
with you oh yeah see there you go good
also attainment um yeah that's all it is
little back and forth also as I said
since if you're seeing the shows New
Year's Eve so since the new year is
coming I also started doing as I said
like a like about an hour long show of
just me reading scary stories most of
them are like older stories that are
like public domain some of them are my
own stories that I wrote you know and
some of them are like kind of reddit
stories that I so it's not a lot of them
are from that because you know there's
there's a subreddit on there where
people are like they post stories that
they say oh it's okay to read these like
for your YouTube channel or whatever but
most of them really aren't very good so
they're like either poorly written or
they're just kind of like and yeah so a
lot of them weren't that so a lot of
them are kind of like classic like scary
stories or my own stories I want to put
them on this channel right I am gonna
have its own playlist that's what I
would do the playlist is gonna be called
the witching hour um like I said I have
seven episodes finished right so um I'll
probably just put one up a week or one
every two weeks or something like that
ever really just said I'll probably put
them up on like Wednesday or Thursday
this is okay this is this is my idea
okay
let's get like 10 of them recorded okay
and I drop them all around the same time
that way they're sitting cuz if you only
drop one up there
it won't attract a lot of attention
online for that genre yeah but if you
drop them all then you'd be taking more
seriously because there's a lot of them
they're there maybe well I could maybe
do like a month's worth at a time like
more of them and then cuz I wanted again
like kind of ahead because I try to
record one a week right these are easier
to do than the shows because I can just
let go in my little sound pot it means
that more of them to make an impression
yeah that's like another one ever that I
can schedule it cuz you do one of the
new things I think you
- and I think this is a fairly new thing
but you can schedule like you can upload
them and then schedule when you want
them to go - I would do which is nice
because it took them a long time to get
around it I dropped three or four of
them instantly and then start dropping
them once a week yeah I guess I can do
that that's what I would do because if
there's just one there I don't think
they'll attract a lot of attention but
there's four of them people that are
into that I'll sit there listening off
and listen all four of them could be
four hours of scary stuff yeah they'll
also probably you know maybe share the
[ __ ] so the people you'll get
subscribers yeah that would be cool if
you drop one of them it might not make
enough big enough splash to be noticed
that's true yeah I'm done yeah I get a
point all right so let's start talking
about the Lizzie Borden case as I said
easily one of American crime history's
most famous cases particularly 19th
century cases I can't really think of
another 19th century case it's as famous
as this one like I said they've made
like a ton of movies about it it was a
media sensation in its day it was and a
lot of people have compared it to know
Jake to the OJ case back in the 30s
because the book that I read was
actually written by a guy that the book
came out in 1937 kind of like when they
kidnapped that kid yeah I was gonna say
the Lindbergh did the Bruno Hauptmann
you know the Bruno Hauptmann case that
was like so it was kind of like this big
huge thing and it was another thing
where like newspapers were like
competing to you know print all this
stuff the interesting thing about this
though is that it seems that a lot of
the media at the time were kind of on
Lizzy's side like they kind of thought
that she was innocent that like the
police were you know bumbling and inapt
and that they were persecuting her
because at the time I mean she was kind
of from a wealthy family you know she
was a Sunday school teacher she was you
know that I'll kind of get into like she
wasn't like up in society or anything
like that even that they had a lot of
money but she was seen as just this kind
of like unimpeachable like spinster type
character and I think there was a
perception at the time that women could
not do anything of this brutality yeah
which she the cops knew better yeah it's
it's very murderous down in that you
the ghetto back in the day I've seen
photographs crime-scene photographs that
the stuff that was done by women yeah
white women yeah yeah and they were
killing each other with hatchets and
guns and [ __ ] that goes back 4,000 yeah
I mean it is much much rarer I will
admit that it is much much rarer for a
woman to kill somebody like say with a
hatchet usually there are you know there
were a lot of women murderers but you
they tended to use less ostentatious
methods let's say they attended T's
poison or sometimes firearms just off
the top of my head a woman taking a
hatchet to a guy or think you know where
you know it's almost always a case of
some kind of abuse yeah that she just
can't take it anymore yeah and where she
just gets scared or or whatever and then
she clubs the dude to death or is he
wait for that sucker to go to sleep and
then she beats him to death I mean
that's happened a lot well yes she can't
face the attacker you know mean he's
super abusive in denge maybe he's bigger
than her oh yes they just can't take it
you know I mean so that she just loses
it you know so that's usually what this
it what happens that's the pattern
although I actually back in those times
I do kind of think that there might have
been something else going on in Lizzie
Borden's case um so because she was kind
of an unusual woman I'm not saying that
she did I don't know if she did it or
not I would tend to think that she
probably did just because there really
doesn't seem to be any other compelling
suspect but like I said and and the way
she acted like after the murders was a
little seemed a little sketchy um you
know and a lot of her stories kind of
didn't add up and stuff but I don't know
it's it there's like some details in
there that kind of like give me pause
and like I said she was acquitted at the
time and later on I think that um I
don't know if they do this every year
but like some law schools like to kind
of Train lawyers and stuff we'll do this
as a mock trial and usually when they
redo it as a mock trial she is acquitted
again simply because all the evidence
against her was circumstantial you know
what I mean so even if she were tried
today in a court of law I mean obviously
you know today there would have been a
lot more forensic evidence than there
was back into at the time but given the
evidence that was collected from the
crime scene she probably would have been
acquitted today as well just because
there wasn't
enough to convict Iran you have to prove
guilt that's what I mean and there was
still enough doubt that someone else
could have done it now if you two got
her in front of a [ __ ] volatile or
stupid or volatile and stupid jury you
probably could have got a conviction but
usually they probably you know they took
the jury pool of from peers so as people
around her area they were already
sympathetic to her so yes she did really
seem to be played and in a way if she
did do it she was kind of a criminal
genius because she knew that that would
be that that could be used in her favor
right you know what I mean so let's get
into this a little bit so I'm gonna talk
about like the background of the Borden
family now Andrew Jackson Borden who was
Lizzie's father um he was actually like
a kind of a big deal this all happened
in Fall River Massachusetts the murders
happen in 1892 in case you wanted to
know now at the time Fall River was a
fairly prosperous town it was mostly
like textiles it was also a seaport now
the Borden family and it this might
still be nowadays and New England I'm
not really sure but the Borden family
that lived there they were actually all
descended from Richard and Joan Borden
who were English colonists who had
arrived in Rhode Island in 1638 so they
were very deep and then it kind of
spread out like all over New England so
there's still like hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of flag board and families
like from this initial couple now Andrew
Borden was one of the most prominent
citizens of Fall River pretty much
everybody knew who he was now at the
time of his murder he was 70 years old
he was actually one of the richest men
in the city he was president of the
Union Savings Bank
he was also director of the First
National Bank he was the director of the
BMC Durfee safe-deposit and Trust
Company director of the council's of the
Troy cotton wool and manufacturing
company the globe yarn mills and the
merchants manufacturing company and he
was a commercial landlord
that had several buildings that he run
it out to other tenants now according to
most accounts of him he was kind of
admired around town for his thrift and
his business industriousness however he
doesn't seem to have been particularly
likable people thought that he was kind
of a stick-in-the-mud he was a very tall
man he was very thin he was kind of like
wasn't a fun guy
he was very dour very didn't have much
of a sense of humor so he was like
unpleasant to hang around apparently
even though he was admired from afar for
his like business acumen because you
have to and the reason that he might
have been so thrifty I'll get into this
a little bit later but was because
unlike many of his extended relatives
like in the Borden clan most of them had
like inherited their money because this
was a wealthy prominent family he had
actually worked for his his parents had
not been super wealthy he had actually
kind of come up in his own business
making furniture and coffins
he actually had a coffin manufacturing
business and that was very successful so
he actually kind of built his fortune
maybe not from the very ground up but
you know from pretty modest background
those guys don't yeah and most people or
not a hundred percent is self-made yeah
well you can't be it's a you know what I
mean it's like you always have some
start well you always have to save to
have somebody so whether it's your
family or whether it's like you know
something your family yeah friends of
your family yeah you always gotta have
something to start with but I'm just
saying he kept like his parents and
stuff there were pretty modest means so
he actually did build most of his wealth
you know from his own like business
acumen he didn't have a lot of inherited
money now what you know it's who you
know that's true back then and it's true
it's pretty that is very true it's it's
yeah it's sad because I feel like that's
why I had I had a hard time like getting
jobs and stuff like that back in the day
because it's like if you don't know like
a lot of people you're not like yeah it
is harder it is much much hard still do
it I mean I still did it but it's a lot
more luck involved
oh yeah people that are really sent
making money it's generational and
friends and popularity and and then if
you look at the person who's making all
the money they don't really have the
so-called credentials to get to to make
them yeah like I said they just that's
just they just knew someone important
are they you know yeah if you want to
write a lot of money I mean if you want
to make a lot of money you know
universities don't have anything to do
with it nothing to do with this you got
to work into the right Thur most of the
people that are making the big money
right now are running jobs that didn't
exist ten years ago you couldn't go to a
university to learn that how to be a
damn youtuber like [ __ ] we got we have a
hard time making five hundred dollars a
month on YouTube you know I was just
looking they got 12 year old kids making
$100,000 a year and a 12 year old kid I
made $150,000 on YouTube that's here you
know he do discussing at video games cuz
hit all of his subscribers are 12 and
they're all cussing at me I guess in at
the video games in this sitting fed
they're gonna send mommy and daddy's
money my mommy dyes dollar you know one
dollar a month another five million so
we should start cussing it video game no
you could only make that kind of money
cussing a video game if you're [ __ ]
12 yeah it doesn't really work doesn't
work the dog [ __ ] man what I have to say
like back into the [ __ ] 80s and 90s
if my if YouTube had existed back then
my brother would have made like a
million dollars because that's all he
did was cause of video games every we're
talking about like the old Nintendo like
Legend of Zelda [ __ ] what's the one
with Samus and the Mother Brain and all
that yeah Metroid yeah there's yeah
there's no no he was okay he tested that
all they were throwing the [ __ ]
controller and everything I've been
sitting here studying it in my study
there there really is no educational
system in existence today that can
prepare you for what's gonna make money
tomorrow yeah it's it's hard to predict
oh yeah you can't really predict it and
you can't predict that's why I just kind
of like you know we talk about this all
the time it's like we're just doing the
show I'm just like you know what I'm
just gonna do [ __ ] that I'm interested
in if other people are interested that's
cool if they're not interested I don't
really
hair it's like I don't really want to
spend my whole entire life like chasing
after what I think other people are
gonna be interested in because even if
they are interested in something for a
short time and like say we get like you
know two hundred thousand subs or
something cuz we did something that
seemed to like you know hit some kind of
zeitgeist or whatever but it's like how
long is that gonna last yeah it's always
high turnover it's it you know what I
mean it's it's just kind of like here
today gone tomorrow and it's like I
don't really I would rather just have
like an interesting show that kind of
like built a fan base like slowly and
more organically I mean you got guys
that are making a [ __ ] ton of money yeah
on a Star Wars that's what I'm here
turnover for subscribers
yes very fast very because like I said
why not making a lot of money though and
the thing about it too though is that
you know their audience might be very
young and it might be aging out yes it's
like look it I mean I'm old I know that
I'm like you know I'm 47 but it's like
it's do it the old way so it's not well
I mean that's not my audience so it's
like I I can see how even if you were
younger after a few years you would kind
of get sick if it's like man I'm sick of
like some dude just yelling about [ __ ]
like outrage rush it's like it gets
boring and you know so I can see how
that would happen
well that eventually became PewDiePie
and then still eating he makes about a
million dollars a month you're not
really yelling at video games anymore he
does do that but then he just makes fun
of videos that he sees and he's a
personality but that's what celebrity
was back in the television age in the
age anyway it's just that's what I mean
it I don't think like I don't want to be
one of those like old man yells at cloud
where it's just kind of like our old age
kids today what it's not really any
doubt that's what celebrity was back
then like look at like look at let's go
back like really listen when I was a
little kid and [ __ ] like um you know
like Hollywood Squares or [ __ ] like that
most of those hockey ah that's right
well it really was yeah but um it's like
a lot of those celebrities yes and more
actors and stuff like that but some of
them I I was kind of unclear on what
they were famous famous for being famous
and famous for being on Hollywood's yeah
I guess well they were famous I think
they were famous two celebrities because
they
at the same clubs in the same bars and
they were just like like you said they
were a personality and in celebrities
they got drunk with celebrities and
celebrities so if you're gonna go on
Hollywood school yeah come on we're
gonna be on really with you yes tomorrow
hungover yeah that's a lot of it was
that so I don't real goes back to not
what you know but who you know I don't
really so I don't really think the
YouTube thing I you know like I said I
don't want to be one of those old people
is just like decrying yes every day
because they cuz that's been going on
for life in this way thousands of years
like everyone decrying the generation
before for being like stupid or more
shallow or whatever the only difference
is is that it doesn't cost thousands of
dollars for a camera in a studio that's
the only difference and you don't need
television channels yeah that's the only
difference it's like I really don't see
a lot of difference now aside from that
this is just it being like cheaper to
produce which is like I said it's kind
of like the same thing that happened
like in the punk-rock era where
recording your own records became
cheaper and you could do it yourself
right and put out your own flyers and do
your own shows and stuff like that which
prior to that you needed a record
company and they needed to pay and blah
blah blah but you know during the punk
rockers people started doing things
themselves and stuff like that so it's
not really all that different yeah just
as cable dies YouTube takes the place of
television yeah it's and like I said at
this point there's not really much
distinction no this is now television
and we're kind of like public access
channel and everyone is kind of like a
public access channel sort of way and
then our rickety-ass yeah and now it's
getting all homogenized and you know
censorships involved the underground is
now [ __ ] shoot so all of our [ __ ] is
just backed up on [ __ ] shoot too in
case in case they wanted to eliminate us
because eventually eventually YouTube's
gonna become Netflix gonna be something
like yeah well like I said I was like
you know yeah put our shouldn't [ __ ]
shoot it's like there's always gonna be
something like this I don't think I mean
I think this cat I can't get rid of it
the cat is out of the bag I don't I
don't think you can put it back in there
um so that's why I don't worry about it
cuz I'm just like well whatever happens
I'll just if I have to move to some
other platform we'll move to some other
platform it's not really that big of a
deal for me
yeah and that that platform would be
[ __ ] shoot it's the second biggest
one that's growing the fastest yeah so
like I said I already I've been
uploading [ __ ] to there for like a long
time although I have to say that it's
like I I've very hardly ever get
comments on that you well what what
[ __ ] shoot is doing right now it's
backing up everything that's in danger
of getting getting kicked off so now a
lot of people are actually watching and
now that a lot of people are actually
actually watching it what it is it's
kind of like the archive yeah so when
this finally vanishes everybody will
just move over there well the only thing
that the only thing that I don't like
about [ __ ] [ __ ] is that the comments
section is unwieldly to use yeah a lot
of things about a dirt ünzile d but it's
but that's the way youtube was ten years
ago fifteen years ago maybe now I should
say to that like I back up well I upload
the audio version of the show to
archive.org you know the Wayback Machine
all of that so all of our old shows are
there and you know when I upload the
audio it goes to iTunes it goes to pod
mean it goes to like all the other
things but it is backed up on that yeah
boy we got sides right we did yet but
they love it when we go on these [ __ ]
well you know we're kind of like
professional friends they're Latino
whatever I start [ __ ] cut up or we go
on site we get sidetracked they [ __ ]
love that [ __ ] yeah
and that's what they comment on every
time there's comments something that
happened on the side pretty much yeah
yeah all right so we were talking on
Caston man yeah well I'm drinking and
ran broadcasting sounds better so we
were talking about Andrew Borden how
like I said he was known around town
he's very very wealthy but you know not
the most likable dude you know maybe a
little bit of a kind of bummer guy to
hang around now Lizzie and Emma their
upbringing was fairly religious they
went to the central Congregational
Church now Lizzie seemed like she was
really into like church activities she
taught Sunday School including a class I
think there was a class for like
children of recent immigrants to the US
so she was like teaching them Sunday
school she was also in a bunch of
Christian
the Christian Endeavor Society I'm not
entirely sure what that is she was the
secretary treasurer of that she was also
in the women's Christian Temperance
Union and the this I found this very
weird she was also a member of the
ladies fruit and flower mission which
just kind of like what it what even is
that what is that well there was no
internet then there wasn't even really
anything like well lady don't have
nightclubs so you don't do something and
the thing about it too and and I kind of
a lot of documentaries kind of went into
this you know Lizzie Borden she was you
know I hate to use the word spinster
because but that's what they called it
at the time she was unmarried her sister
Emma who was 10 years older was also
also never married so the tradition was
if you weren't married you pretty much
just lived in your parents house forever
yeah you didn't move out on your own
that would have been very scandalous
like for a single woman to live on her
own that just wasn't done if a woman
wasn't married by 19 she wasn't gonna
get married that's what I mean so it's
like she was kind of even though
nowadays like you know when the murders
happened Lizzie Borden was like 32 years
old yeah she's no lady by those that's
what I mean it's like nowadays that's
young but it's like back then she would
have been like you know an old hag at
that stage because she hadn't married
and a lot of them looked like old hags
they did go something about the
environment back then they they're a I
don't know maybe just a photography you
know didn't have really lifelike
photographs
well everybody you had to sit there for
a really long time it was one thing
without moving the hair the makeup the
lack of physical fitness the bad diet
bad food not real this you know spotty
hygiene they kind of looked bad all of
them it did good yeah no one was no one
was a real fashion plate man I gotta say
Lizzie was actually not a bad-looking
woman I don't think I mean she got kind
of hefty later on but I you know she was
a perfectly she was a perfectly
reasonable looking woman but it's like I
just don't she didn't really seem to be
all that interested in marriage or in
men in general but you know they're
saying that it's like so her and Emma
both lived in their parents house and
which would have been kind of an
accepted thing at the time because like
I said women did not
live like a single woman lived like
living on her own would have been just
like really scandalous but they did
there weren't like a lot of social
outlets because you know they weren't
really up in high society for reasons
which I'll get to in a minute
so it seemed like her only social outlet
was the church so she was always doing
Church [ __ ] because I guess that was
like the only time she got out of the
house and got to like interact with
other people that was the medium that
they had to work with him that's what
I'm saying
it's like there wasn't anything else for
her to do yeah that mean it was like
that one you couldn't have a job it was
still kind of like that as a little kid
you know I mean vit you know going to
Mississippi and then the deep south the
older people were that were around we're
still like that yeah you know I'd hate
to say you know losers today standard
you're a [ __ ] loser yes I mean well
yeah it's just even do anything well
it's very constrictive and it just seems
to me that it's like you know if you
were a woman specifically it's like what
the [ __ ] could you do you couldn't do
anything they were trying to be proper
yeah they were trying to fulfill certain
standards of morality that wakana dumb
yeah you know because they were afraid
of what people would think of him yeah
even though they didn't trust if you
weren't thinking anything about him
well they were though that was kind of
the problem it's like because everybody
had those yeah you know those kind of
restrictive thoughts you know what's
like yeah but I was time talking about I
knew people that were like that and
Mississippi and say oh yeah Hades is a
little kid well yeah that shit's Long
Island this is long as [ __ ] was kind of
like they were still kind of holding on
to that even as late as that yeah when
that had been [ __ ] gone gone sixties
probably yeah easily yeah before name
but you know in that in that place there
were still dry counties their price do
it might be dry count I think there are
that's ridiculous when you think about
it that's just it kills me that like
from County to County yeah like you
can't buy booze at a County because of
some way don't search woman like a long
time with it yeah yeah it is what some
church woman thought a long time like
that woman's been dead yeah
and we're still doing that you have to
drive to the next County
that's really stupid and I think I'm not
really sure about this state or county I
thought at least as far as I remember
from a few years ago I you can buy booze
here obviously because some we buy a lot
of it but I think at certain places you
can't purchase it after a certain time
like at night you know the
ridiculousness
I'm not sure if it's still like that as
if a [ __ ] buys his booze on the
spot i buy my booze in advance that's
what I mean
so what it's like what difference does
it make like you can buy know is it
Walmart after 2:00 a.m. it's like [ __ ]
so what when you buy booze in the middle
of the day yeah right yeah later on
right it doesn't usually drink it it's
shirt people thinking I guess so there's
like well if we tell people that they
can't drink after 2:00 a.m. that they
can't buy booze after doing it while
drinking and they won't know it's like
you got a plan ahead you got a plan
ahead and so you already have it so yeah
so like I said yeah probably because she
had nothing else to do maybe she was a
true believer who knows but she did like
my experience very few of them work
that's what I mean I feel like it was
more social thing and it was kind of
like all you could do and it's just like
what you did so that's probably what
that was now at the time that the
murders happen like I said in the late
1890s or the early 1890s rather Andrew
Borden was living with his second wife
so the the one that was murdered was not
her mother it was her stepmother now the
step mother's name was Abby Durfee gray
um they had actually married what
happened was Andrew Borden had been
married to the first wife who was Sarah
so all of the you know kids it was
Lizzie and Emma who was her older sister
they had also had a sister called Alice
who died when she was two although she
was born before Lizzie was born Sarah
had died during the Civil War not and
not because of the Civil War but just
like while the Civil War was going on
she died when she died Emma there just
when she died Andrew remarried two years
later now when he remarried Abby
Emma the older sister was 12 years old
and Lizzie was not quite three so she
was just like a toddler so Lizzie didn't
really
remember her birthmother all that much
at all so you know you would think that
she would kind of see Abby as a mother
because that was the only mother that
she remembered now the house that they
lived in which still stands it is a
museum and bed-and-breakfast so you can
actually go and sleep in the room we're
happy Borden got murdered if you're into
that it looks exactly the same and they
even have like the crime scene photos
like in there and a lot of people go so
the house and I guess a lot of houses
were like this at the time it was a two
and a half story like a frame house and
it was it's really narrow I saw like
this one documentary that said it was
only 20 feet wide although that can't be
right
but it's pretty narrow look I've saw the
layout it's wider than 20 yeah that's
what I mean I think that was incorrect
but it was one of those houses and I
think you might have brought this up
before it was one of those houses that
didn't have hallways like all of the
rooms like fade into one another yeah
yeah so they've been one in Boston
there's yeah this was in Massachusetts
also yeah tell you what doesn't make any
sense
yeah interior you got to walk through
everybody's room to get to the yeah
that's exactly right and then originally
there was no kitchen in there yeah
they're just weird you know there was a
place where they how the hell did they
live well there was what were you guys
doing there was a place where they
prepared food but it wasn't really a
kitchen by the by today's standards yeah
now the one we live in it had been
turned into a kitchen well I would hope
so
but yeah I mean originally I don't I'm
to need a kitchen yeah I don't think it
was there it was like weird [ __ ] like I
don't think there was a sink and there
was water in there but you know I mean
it was just basins and it's bizarre and
then there wasn't any kind of like
electrical appliances or gas stoves or
anything there was just like you know
originally there was like cast-iron
stoves that were in the Centers of the
rooms yeah or in the centers of where
you I mean like I said I'm just crazy
I'm sure it worked out for the people
like how they lived back then but
because we don't have any context for
that really it's harder Stan it's like
for us area like what the [ __ ] it's like
how the hell did you I think it was
always like in the
room a big basket filled with wood is
one of the things and I think there was
other stuff about like big barrels of
water in there yeah you know big jugs
and barrels of water you know and when
you don't well you don't see what they
were working with because it's all along
gone it's hard to understand why the
layouts where the way yeah they were
because the land of this house is super
weird in lycra duration just like the
front the front stairs led up to there
was like a landing and then there was
Lizzie's room that led to Emma's room
that led to the master or led to the
guest room and then you had to take the
back stairs to go up to the master
bedroom but then there was a door
between the master bedroom and I believe
Lizzie's room there was no bad there
were connecting doors no bathrooms
either because they always had
chamberpot they all just had chamber
pots yeah it's weird as [ __ ] and it was
like an appliance you damn had in your
room it looked like a big cabinet little
cabinet and it had a little top aren't
they opened up and there was like a
thing that hold Bowl and you just do
your business there and you take the
bowl out and put it under cupboards in
the bottom and shut it and it's just
like and then you lived around it was
Bowl let's put the poop in the drawer
bowls of [ __ ] passing your house and
yeah that's all right then you know you
use like it used it until I guess it was
full and then you threw it out a window
guys there's something yeah it's well
the thing that cracks me up it just
cracks me up to think of these proper
Victorian people with their 50 million
layers of clothing on they took like an
hour to [ __ ] put on every day and
it's like they're basically like you
said just pooping in a bowl and just
like people would be [ __ ] yeah and
it's just like funny to me that they
were like trying to go around being so
prim and proper and I'm like you're
pooping in a bowl and leaving it in your
room just like stop it with the proper
Ness so now the house where they lived
um like I said it's still there
it was a nice house however it was not
in the wealthy part of the neighborhood
even though Andrew Borden was very
wealthy and could have afforded to live
upon the in the fashionable neighborhood
which is called the hill if he had
wanted to this house was actually
kind of in a more middle class part of
the city one of the documentaries
pointed out there like even on the same
street on the corner was a Chinese
Laundry with Oh something that she would
never have seen yeah in the very upper
class that was something that you kind
of looked down upon moving around those
havens that's what I mean so there's so
this was like a largely like I said it
was a middle class kind of neighborhood
it was it was mostly Irish Catholic
there was like a lot of merchants and
stuff
however andrew borden appears to have
wanted to live here because it was
within walking distance of a lot of them
the business district like where a lot
of his businesses were and it was easy
for him to get there and he didn't
really seem to care all that much about
high society kind of [ __ ] and like I
said he was very some people would say
he was a miser he was cheap I don't
think I would go that far because
there's like some evidence that he
actually did spend money on his
daughters and stuff and he wasn't that
much of a tightwad but he was because he
had been brought up you know in a modest
background and made his own money he was
a little bit penny-pinching and he
didn't really want to spend all this
money to just like impress other people
I guess so it was a decent house but it
wasn't it was kind of in an
unfashionable part of town also it did
not have running water inside the house
which wealthy people at the time would
have had it did not even have gas lamps
like you know gas that was piped into
the house which also wealthy people at
the time would have had so basically
they had to there was running water in
the barn but so you had to go out to the
barn like to the spigot or whatever and
get water out of the barn if he wanted
any running water so they didn't have
hot water they didn't have gas lamps at
infinity anything like that was rich
people stuff well they were rich that
cost more but they didn't come up with
that yeah they didn't think it was a
necessity yeah that's what I mean
yeah now this is that was that was
newfangled yeah to have gas and to have
running water you know yeah in her days
you know I imagine I bet her dad didn't
grow up with running water
well no I'm sure he didn't because he
was 70 at this point he didn't he didn't
think that was a necessity yeah [ __ ]
that old newfangled [ __ ]
they don't run on water long enough
water doesn't have to run just go to the
barn again well they had a maid so with
you know if the maid goes and gets it
you don't have to go it's like
everything's easier when you don't have
to do it is funny
they weren't even at they they weren't
even at the level of Roman rich people
yeah because they had run of water yeah
I saw the bike I saw valves and pipes
that they could make it was like to cut
him out of 1920s
ancient Romans couldn't [ __ ] they
could handle their business yeah they
knew about technology they weren't
pooping in a bowl and just not in a
drawer well they're poor people were
well I don't think they had what you
would call commodes yeah either talking
about our toilets yeah Romans didn't
have that but they had a way to get rid
of waste yeah yeah Ryan water which you
think would be one of the first things
you think of I guess who the hell is
hard though because you've got to flush
it and it goes somewhere and then there
has to be water in the bowl to keep the
gasses in the stink
yeah from coming back up out of the dam
what do you call it
sewage system yeah so it was kind of
tricky
it wasn't the thinking it's not as easy
as you know we we look at a toilet when
it works now and you go of course
obviously I got the bowl in the bat you
got valves and everything but in the
Victorian way it would have been to make
things straight straight shots down and
it doesn't work you're gonna have traps
yeah this is where their water well yeah
gases down and I think even in wealthy
communities until quite late I think
that they were basically even houses
that had something that approximating a
toilet or something like that it just
kind of went into like a pile to do it
like over there and then somebody had to
like come and collect went down into a
damn septic tank yeah but there wasn't
water in the bowl to keep the stink down
so they you know you pried the cork it
or the [ __ ] like that you know weird
thinking but eventually they came out
with it was a company called the crapper
company figured you know what I think
that's an urban legend ah but that guy's
name was Thomas Crapper I think yeah
yeah that's I saw pictures of it
and on it crapper yeah that was the
company I broke that to you but I'm
pretty I think that I don't know it is
true I think it is true
me well you know what arguing over the
existence of toilets in the name but I
was late 18-hundreds all offensive I
think it was just a very late eighteen
hours you had the first modern toilets
yeah that did stink to high heaven yeah
yeah no like I said I think everybody's
stuck back then and everyone was just
you know I mean I don't think that if a
new a stink was that's what I mean
because everybody's Duncan that was just
you just learn to deal with it like
after why you don't notice that anymore
and they were they were and they would
have to keeping that [ __ ] in a pot right
with a lid on it in the summer without
AC well and yeah I kind of want to
mention that in the in this case too
when I get to that point but it's like
yeah not to do with poop when it is
falling we live in Florida alright yeah
this house is [ __ ] clean we have
modern amenities and when this [ __ ]
place is loses power in the summer
doesn't take long no take longer a
couple days later you're like mountains
was like mildew in here yeah that's
because it well because we lost power
during a hurricane last year the year
before and it was out for what two days
three days there like that and yeah like
within six hours starting to smell like
mold in there yeah because moisture yeah
air conditioning because it's humid it's
[ __ ] air dry Florida and the air the
natural ambient air is moist enough to
get inside your damned carpets yeah and
they smell like a wet carpet start
smelling like a damn wet dog
yep so none of these houses in modern
Florida none of the new houses are ever
or they're not equipped for actual
survival say like in a post-apocalyptic
situation where there's no power or no
air conditioning they just the houses
would fall apart in [ __ ] in ten years
easily
well yeah everything late and
particularly where we live in flow this
is like this used to be a swamp and
you're constantly fighting back it
retiring the swamp
it wants to be because it wants to be as
well yeah so you really have to like
keep without electricity trying to keep
the nature at bay without electricity
these houses would vanish very quickly
yeah wouldn't take long
they but I mean they would very quickly
be overrun with plants for sure
plants and insects insects mold
everything mold like I said you can
barely keep the insects out and disease
like when you're trying to look at the
powers on and [ __ ] like that the only
thing that survives these kind of
environments without power or what they
built down here in the Victorian era
yeah where the house has two or three
stories in each floor is almost like 18
feet tall
yeah so you have a place for the heat to
go and then the windows the windows
would stretch all the way down from the
floor to the ceiling and then you open
it up lots of them yeah basically you
didn't have walls half the time yeah you
just open all the walls so the damn air
could circulate through it then they had
they had later on the added fans
belt-driven fans I remember I remember
him
yeah when I was a little kid Mississippi
something houses - you can't
air-conditioned them yeah those houses
they're not insulated I was like I don't
know how people live now because my
grandmother she moves in Jordan from
Tennessee in 1958 and her house which is
still there other people live in it now
obviously because she has passed away
but for many years her house did not
have air conditioning yeah and I often
and even later when I lived there it was
it only had a window unit yeah so
basically you could sleep in the house
but you had to sleep in the dining room
or the living room that was like right
adjacent to it was right in front of
where the air conditioner was because
the bedrooms in the back of the house
that [ __ ] was like it was like a sauna
back there and so you couldn't sleep and
it would have been miserable back in
those days because in the summertime
you'd have to open every window yeah you
would just be like crawling with bugs
crawling with bugs and they didn't have
screens back then yeah that's so all the
bugs we come in that's like sleeping
outside you might as well camp outside
yeah the only screen they had was the
damn screen that went around the bed
yeah the bed the bed sheet Kurt or what
do you call it the canopy yeah they had
a canopy and they had a screen that went
down through there to keep the
mosquitoes out the house of mud fill
with mosquitoes yeah it's like know what
everyone [ __ ] diseases back then
mosquitoes and palmetto bugs Rosalee
instead of n everyone [ __ ] disgusting
I just can't imagine it [ __ ] I can't
imagine like I said I guess they didn't
have any memories of Mississippi where
old people living in kinda like those
conditions and we're not talking about
[ __ ] up houses these were beautiful
houses they were like beautiful
Victorian plantation houses there's no
way for air conditioning yeah and no way
to put screens on those windows the
windows were huge yeah they're basically
like doors that didn't go all the way
down to the damn floor remember yeah
like some how to interview the vampire
yeah and you open that [ __ ] up and they
didn't have damn walls
half the time each room had [ __ ] four
[ __ ] huge glass windows hand-blown
stuff from the from you know from the
eighteen hundred's if you broke a window
[ __ ] bad you were [ __ ] out of luck
yeah hire somebody coming in cut a
special piece of glass because remember
how this windows were mm-hmm each window
was like seven pieces of glass was all
very ornate diamond shapes and [ __ ]
they're really nice but really nice but
miserable yeah by today's standards but
they didn't notice that [ __ ] back there
well like I said they didn't know any
better you know any better any better so
like I said this was a nice house like I
said it's still there you can still
visit it it's a museum and a
bed-and-breakfast at this point but it
wasn't in the best part of town it
wasn't where out like all the other
wealthy people and I lived and obviously
andrew borden could have afforded to
live there had he wanted to however he
didn't really seem to care about it now
on the other hand Lizzie and Emma were
very put out that they were not living
on the hill with all the other
fashionable families and it seems that
there was some resentment there that
they felt like their father's frugality
let's call it that was kind of keeping
them from living the life that they felt
that they deserved so apparently they
complained about it a lot that's just
too retro what this who their friends
and stuff it's like you know we could
afford to live there with the gas lamps
and the running water and it's like you
know we could be up there in the society
with the other prominent families you
know and we could be doing the things
that prominent families would do but
they were denied that and I feel like
they were kind of resentful about it now
like I said it doesn't seem that andrew
borden was
complete Scrooge though because there is
some evidence that he did by like
wealthy you know like a kind of
expensive things for his daughters they
think that he bought Lizzie and or Emma
like kind of you know diamonds diamond
jewelry
he bought Lizzie the sealskin cape which
will kind of factor it into the case a
little bit and we'll talk about that a
little bit he also in 1890 two years
before the murders he apparently paid
for Lizzie to go on a very expensive
like tour of Europe with some of their
wealthier cousins now you would think
that this would like shut her up because
it's like okay just go to Europe for a
few months ago too so you know hang out
with the rich people or whatever but
apparently this made her even more
resentful because she saw the life that
she was missing out on it's like you
know we could be doing this all the time
because we have as much money as them
and instead we're just sitting around
the house without any running water
without any gas and without you know all
of these other social things that all
these other people in our family are
doing so apparently that pissed her off
even more now there is also some
evidence that the relationship between
Lizzie and her older sister Emma and
their stepmother Abby wasn't the best um
as I said now emma had been 12 years old
when abby married her father so she
actually did remember her birth mother
Lizzie did not Emma
apparently called Abbey by her first
name she didn't call her mom or mother
or whatever Lizzie called her mrs.
Borden so apparently back in the day
from what I could gather from everything
that I read about this I think that
Lizzie actually did call her Abbey or
mother for a time because like I said
this was the only mother that she
remembered because she was not even
three like when her when her dad
remarried however there was kind of a
family conflict after which she began
referring to Abbey as mrs. Borden what
ended up happening was that Andrew
Borden gave a house to I believe
Abby's sister now
Lizzie and Emma were really upset about
this because you know like what the [ __ ]
are you like you're giving property to
our stepmothers sister like you know our
stepmothers family and you're not giving
us any and it seemed unfair so they like
kind of complained about export and the
wealth away from the dam yeah yeah so
you know they I don't think they were
you know they were just mad because like
you know why why are they getting all
this stuff and we're not getting
anything so to kind of appease them it
seems that andrew borden gave them he
gave them the deed to their
grandfather's house and he said okay
well you you know you guys can own this
house it was a rental property because
like I said he owned many and you can
have like the rental income from it and
manage it and everything like that so
they either gave them it or he gave them
it for like a dollar or some like
ridiculously low some like that now
apparently they ran it as a rental
property for a short period of time
however because like I said this wasn't
like a real fashionable or desirable
neighborhood the rents were kind of low
and the maintenance cost on the house
was very high so the sisters were kind
of like NAMM not really into this being
a landlord type of thing so andrew said
well okay well I will buy the house back
from you and apparently he gave them
five thousand dollars for the house
which in today's money is about a
hundred and forty grand and that was at
his you know they didn't ask him for the
money apparently but he said you know
I'll buy it back from you and take it
off your hands so like I said he wasn't
he was thrifty but he wasn't like a
super cheapskate like when they'd
complained he was like here have a house
and stuff and then when they didn't want
to do it anymore he did offer to buy it
back from them for apparently more than
it was worth
okay so he wasn't like a Scrooge or
anything like that
now there has also been some kind of
because here's the thing
now as I said Lizzie was in the habit of
like I said after that whole thing
happened with the property apparently
that really pissed her off and that was
when evidently she started referring to
Abbey as mrs. Borden rather than Abbey
or mother or whatever but
they hadn't made named Bridget she had
worked in the house for three years now
she said that there didn't really seem
to be that much animosity in the house
between Abby and Lizzy they said now
Lizzy doesn't usually eat with the
family like she doesn't take meals with
them which was a little unusual she
spent a lot of time like in her own room
but you know I I don't think like
Bridget said that there weren't like a
lot of fights between them and stuff now
Emma the older sister she said that the
relationship between Lizzy and her
father was actually fairly close and the
relationship between Lizzy and Abby was
quote-unquote cordial however some other
friends of Lizzy said that Lizzy used to
complain about her stepmother all the
time one of them stating that Lizzy had
once called a be quote a mean
good-for-nothing old thing mm-hmm so you
know like I said that was a friend of
Lizzie's that said that she said that
so let's um actually look we're almost
in an hour I need another drink
and you need another drink so we're
gonna take a break and when we come back
we are going to talk about the murders
and we are going to talk about all the
theories that swirl them like what
happened a lot it's not thinking the
plot is gonna fit it's gonna thicken in
this second half yeah so uh stay tuned
for that Tom's gonna go refresh these
drinking we will be back in just a few
minutes I'm pretty soon your boys
sitting on Mama's keyboard see no mames
cable can't date yeah you don't care do
you
you're just a kitty you don't care about
typing right you just want to get better
and that's all you care about that's
okay Sunday morning
the party just does not want to get
outbid ya know you miss leap in there
all morning mommy had to climb out why
don't you because that's our mommy sweet
she's just snuggled right up in my
armpit and just stayed there oh my
goodness look at her little legs are so
funny
her little legs look like well
drumsticks okay FC Buki yeah I'm sorry
I'm keeping you awake being lazy on
Sunday morning you love true-crime
I love true-crime and I've spent the
last three years compiling a series of
the most intriguing unsolved murders of
the 20th century it's called the
faceless villain and volume three is
available now featuring such fascinating
cases as the Caddy murders the carry
babies case the Frog Boys the al-qasr
murders and the inokashira park
dismemberment incident the faithless
villain volume three is an involving
exploration of unsolved slang spanning
the years from 1980 to 1999 pick up your
copy and print or eBook formats on
Amazon or download the audiobook version
from audible.com and get ready for a
chilling journey through modern crime
history
yeah all right
we are back tom has refilled his drink I
actually didn't need to refill my nuts a
little bit left yep talking about the
Lizzie Borden case and now we're going
to talk about the actual day of the
murders which was Thursday August 4th
1892 now as was their custom the Borden
family was up fairly early on this
particular day now Emma Borden the older
sister of Lizzie Borden Emma was 42
years old at this stage
she was actually not in the house she
had gone to visit friends in Fair Haven
which was a town about 15 miles away so
she wasn't in the house at the time also
in the house was the Borden sisters
Uncle John now this was John Moores now
he was actually the brother of their
biological mother who had passed away
many years before now he had apparently
the day before the murders he had turned
up unannounced and he was apparently
planning to stay in the house overnight
but he hadn't like brought any luggage
or anything like that this wasn't all
that unusual because John Moores
actually he managed a lot of like
business affairs for Andrew Borden and
he actually visited the family several
times a year so it wasn't all that
strange for him to turn up to stay at
the house because he had like a lot of
business interest in Falls River so he
would you know a few times a year he
would turn up at their house and stay
there and like you know do his business
in town and then like go back to
Dartmouth where he was from so on this
particular day August 4th 1892 the first
person up in the house was as you would
imagine was Bridget Sullivan the maid
she woke up at 6:00 a.m. she was
actually Irish she had come to the to
the United States in 1886 and had
started working for the Borden's in 1889
now one thing that was very interesting
was that both Emma and Lizzie even
though this girl's name was Bridget they
actually called her Maggie
because that was the name
of their former maid so it's almost like
they couldn't be bothered to like learn
another name because she was just like a
lowly servant or whatever so they called
her Maggie and I guess Bridget didn't
really have much choice but to answer to
it because unless you would get paid or
whatever so you know that's kind of nice
yeah it's kind of some [ __ ] this [ __ ]
it is kind of like and like I said
talking about this is like a real class
or in it it is very it is like we're
gonna call you the same and I I mean
like I said I read a book that came out
in 1937 it was about this case and it
had the whole trial transcripts and
everything like that and a lot of people
apparently thought of Lizzie and Emma to
a lesser extent as they were very um
haughty
they were very society and like I said
they were kind of resentful that they
had all this money but we're not living
the high life as they apparently thought
that they were entitled to so I guess
that was another that was some little
like passive-aggressive thing they could
do was just like refer to the servant as
the name of the previous sermon because
there's like we couldn't even be
bothered to like learn what your name is
we're just gonna call you by the name of
the last girl yes I'm kind of get a
feeling about what the environment is I
mean they're they feel that they're
being held back by their dad yeah I do
think that there was a there was an
aspect of that because like I said I
don't think there was a lot of animosity
between losing her dad necessarily there
was a lot between Lizzie and her
stepmother by all accounts but I do feel
like there was some [ __ ] that they
thought that their dad was holding them
back from the life that they thought
that they deserved they're seeing this
guy some from another era yeah they're
just putting up with him yeah he's throw
back yeah he definitely did seem like
that like I said he was kind of a little
bit like I said I don't want to say
cheapskate or tightwad or anything like
that he was thrifty we'll say that so
the maid Bridget was 26 years old at
this point now she comes downstairs she
had a room in the Attic
she comes down route 6 a.m. she builds a
fire in the kitchen and starts cooking
breakfast an hour later uh Andrew and
Abby Borden
husband and wife they came down to
breakfast also John Morse came down for
breakfast Andrew at the stage as I said
was 70 years old his wife was six
for was about 64 years old so they came
down to eat breakfast with their
houseguest who was you know Lizzie and
Emma's Uncle John and they kind of sat
around the table this was about 7:00
a.m. they sat on the table for about an
hour discussing things business and
various other things a little before
8:00 a.m. John Mark John Morse left the
house he was gonna go visit some
relatives at a house about a mile away
he took a streetcar I believe and was
seen on the streetcar so you know
that'll factor in the case later after
he left the house Andrew Borden locked
the screen door after him now apparently
this was something that was kind of um
you know even though this is so weird
okay so apparently there had been a
break-in at the house in 1891 like the
year before and so after this break-in
and I'll get into that in a minute but
Andrew Borden had been apparently kind
of paranoid about security so the front
door like the screen door and everything
had like three different locks on it so
he always kept it like the minute that
anybody left the house he would lock the
[ __ ] doors also all the rooms
upstairs and as I said they were all
like adjoining they all like opened into
one another those were all kept locked
as well um Andrew had a key to like a
lot of the house but he kept them he
kept them in plain sight but he kept all
the doors locked pretty much all the
time now some of the ones upstairs I
could see that as kind of like maybe
that was a privacy issue because like I
said there was no halls like all the
rooms like opened up into one another
which yeah you would want to know
yeah you would want to keep your [ __ ]
locked and between like I understand
that but um front door back door side
door everything like that it's like he
kept it locked and there was like
multiple locks on there I don't know
what the [ __ ] they were [ __ ] thinking
I mean I don't the people that
engineered those houses also lived in
them yeah didn't they have any kind of
concept of privacy I guess nah I guess
not
or they wouldn't have designed them like
I mean they say China's like that that
the Chinese have no expectation of
privacy they don't know anything about
it I think it that might be like that
that's what I mean I think at that stage
like I said if there had been any
concepts of privacy I don't think they
would have designed houses in that
fashion right so I think the fact what
that was just like how people lived like
it was constantly under societal
scrutiny and to get to like for example
to get to the guest room where the Uncle
John Morris was staying you had to go
through as far as I was my understanding
you had to go through the Lizzie's room
and Emma's room yeah to get to the guest
room or you would have to go up the back
stairs and go through the master bedroom
and then into like that's ridiculous I
lived in well [ __ ] it doesn't
make any goddamn sense like I said as
far as the other person's name from a
modern person has to live in there by
themselves yeah you know man you have to
hear like yeah because lately [ __ ] out
of here who the [ __ ] want somebody like
traipse ins walk remember so never go to
the can yeah every 10 minutes I walk
into my [ __ ] room I don't like people
walking in our room anytime kind of
[ __ ] weird so some are right now a
couple minutes after John Morris left
the house to go on his you know visiting
the relatives Lizzy comes downstairs now
she had not eaten breakfast with the
family apparently it was not her habit
to do so she had slept a little bit late
she came downstairs but she said she
wasn't hungry
she had a cup of coffee and maybe ate a
cookie now there had been like a couple
of days prior to this there had been
perhaps a stomach bug perhaps food
poisoning something like that going
around this household and it's
speculated that maybe Lizzie had still
had a touch of that and maybe that's why
she wasn't hungry
um Bridget had a bit of it as well
because she said shortly after breakfast
she had had to go outside and throw up
what had happened was that two days
prior to the murders
both Andrew and Abby Borden had been
violently ill in the middle of the night
and had both vomited several times which
is what made me think of the whole you
know pooping in the bowl type of thing
because I remember seeing a documentary
a long time ago about this and you have
to imagine this was in August it was
Massachusetts yes but this was an
unusually hot summer um it was over a
hundred degrees
yeah before noon on this particular day
which is some Florida [ __ ] right there
think about that [ __ ] so I imagine since
it was the middle of the night yeah that
Andrew and Abby had barked into these
bowls many times and it's just yeah and
that he in the heat
yeah and fermented yeah so that's
something that's kind of stuck with me
all here taking them like imagine how
that like this is Mel woulda made you
barf again yeah we cry we take so much
[ __ ] for granted I do I mean we have air
conditioning yeah you know we have known
I was water we have toilets yeah when I
was living in Brazil back in the 80s
that air conditioner was very rare
it got hot there all right but it was
cool it was because everything is made
out of concrete yeah you know I mean in
concrete kind of Rita it stays cold so
it's oh yeah hearing this big contour in
this big concrete apartment complex but
for some reason and the ceilings were
high you know yeah for some reason it
you got used to it it didn't seem hot I
don't think it was but we got
comfortable quickly yeah uh you know at
because the construction of the houses
well I lived I lived in one of those
Victorian type houses no didn't take oh
it didn't stay going like that it
doesn't stay cold and it doesn't stay
warm
there's just no insulation one way or
the other and the thing about and maybe
this conditions were the same but I mean
in Florida the thing about it is that
even when it's hot like and I've heard
this about people that like live in like
desert type areas like Arizona or New
Mexico it's it's hot but it's like dry
yeah and it's cold at night in Florida
the problem is that even if there is a
breeze it's a hundred percent vanity a
hot wet breeze so it's not like it and
in a way like sometimes they're like oh
well it rains every day that just makes
it worse because it makes it more
oppressive and like more humid because
after it with little only rain for like
a few like half an hour and then all of
a sudden it's like sonic and it's like
it's steamy it's always pretty much 100
percent humidity here yeah it's just it
doesn't matter if it's hot or cold
yeah coal was penetrating too but
there's a podcast there's a there's a
youtuber named sargon of akkad from
england and he came here for a visit
right up there too right just up the
street right up the street
where where um Disneyland is and he did
it he did a livestream out there on a
balcony of Disney hotel he just couldn't
believe it
up there about 30 days up there 30
floors above the heat going I can't
believe it because there's no way to
describe this to anyone who's never been
to Florida
well it says this is like being in
Satan's ass crack this is it's like
being a burger wet hot yank it's yeah
that's what it's like yeah you just
can't sweat
that's it yeah well and that's another
thing because like humans have evolved
it's like sweat and it's supposed to
evaporate which in normal conditions
that works but in Florida doesn't work
because it's not dry enough to dry so
basically you just sweat and that just
builds up yeah so you just Lanie heat so
honestly and even sometimes and we have
you know feel like you didn't dry off
yeah so because you're just like still
sticky some summers I just say [ __ ] it
I'm staying indoors I yeah yeah I think
we have been entire summers we're just
like rarely go outside except for maybe
here to the car I guess yeah that's like
and I did that when I was a kid - it's
like everything once summer came
everybody's like yeah we're just gonna
sit in here but air conditioned don't
let her outside if you're the have to go
arable but yeah so now one speculation
like like I said nobody is entirely sure
why a lot of the family members had been
sick apparently they had all been
vomiting and stuff some speculation was
that it was food poisoning because from
what I could determine they had been
eating off the same leg of mutton for
from between four to six days like it
started out like when it was still fresh
apparently they ate it as like a leg of
mutton but I guess it was a lot of
leftovers so they kind of like took some
of it and then they would eat it cold
and then they made some of it into soup
yeah but there was no cold then because
and there's no right and so they ate off
it for several and like it was pretty
gross because it's like I'm sitting
there like reading some of the old
newspaper reports it's like they're
eating like
button soup for breakfast I'm like what
the [ __ ] are you thinking no wonder he
felt like [ __ ] yeah there was no real
refrigeration then they had ice boxes
but they didn't yeah they didn't have an
ice box in the boarding house yeah but
if you've ever dealt with an ice chest
or an ice box
they don't really keep anything cold
they just mostly not 100 degree heat
yeah because I said this was unusual
yeah it was summer at a hundred degrees
that ice box are probably about 70
degrees in there which which is that's
room temperature for us that I deal yeah
which means food was spoil and I'm
pretty sure they eat they ate lots of
rotten food brawl I didn't even notice
that it was rotten because they were
probably just used to eating [ __ ] that
was right so so a lot of people pointed
out that maybe it was this mutton
because they'd been eating often for
several days there had also been some
swordfish that they had eaten which
could have been the cause of some well
fish goes red it does yeah quick so um
so it may have been food poisoning yeah
so so like I said there had been this
kind of illness going around the house
food poisoning prior so on the day of
the murders is about a quarter past nine
andrew borden leaves the house and he
goes downtown like down to the city to
take care of his business interests he
had like a some calls to make he was
gonna go in the banks and check on all
his stuff and you know like he usually
did he was making his rounds Abby Borden
the stepmother she actually went
upstairs to make the bed in the guest
room that John Moores was staying in
because apparently Bridget they had a
maid Bridget she was the only servant in
the house apparently she did not clean
up the bedrooms
she only cleaned other parts of the
house the bedrooms I guess were the
responsibility of the people that looked
in the bedrooms so Abby went up there to
kind of straighten up John Morse's room
the guest room at this point she also
asked Bridget to please go outside and
wash all the windows on the house 9:30
Abby Borden comes downstairs for a few
minutes and says that she needed to get
fresh pillowcases for the bed so she
gets fresh pillowcases and then she goes
back upstairs to the guest room Bridget
who is the maid she goes outside she
goes to the barn to get pails and to get
some water
cuz like I said the barn was the only
place where there's running water so she
goes in there to get all that stuff and
she starts washing the windows on the
outside of the house so she's doing that
they also think she paused for a few
moments to talk to another serpent girl
who worked for the Kelly's next door
they were kind of like talking over the
fence she finished the outside of the
windows at about 10:30 and then goes
back inside and starts washing the
windows on the inside so about 10:45
andrew borden arrives home I don't know
if this was earlier than expected or if
this was about the time that he usually
came home because it could be that he
wasn't feeling all that well so he came
home earlier than he would have normally
I'm not really entirely sure I've seen
sources saying those things now
apparently he's trying to get in the
house and his I guess his key wouldn't
work I don't know if like the lock was
stock or the door was stuck or something
like that and they were like I said
there were three locks on the door
because they were very careful to lock
the doors after somebody left
so apparently Andrew Borden was trying
to get into the house and couldn't get
in so he had to ring the doorbell so
Bridget had to come down and let him in
you know into the house now at this
point
apparently Lizzie came downstairs and
she told her father that Abby had gone
out because a message had come to the
house like a note had come to the house
earlier saying that a friend of hers
across town was sick and that she had
gone out to visit them hmm this was not
the case as we will soon see so andrew
borden takes the key to his bedroom
because like I said all the all the
doors were locked at all times he takes
his bedroom key off the shelf and he
goes back up the back stairs because
that was the only way that you could get
to his room you couldn't really it you
could get there from the front staircase
but you had to go through Lizzie's room
and yeah it was so he goes at the back
stairs and he comes um he was up there
for a couple of minutes and then he came
back down and he decides that he's going
to take a nap on the sofa because like I
said apparently he hadn't been feeling
very well the last couple of days at
this point
Lizzie decides that she's gonna iron
some handkerchiefs like you do
and starts to heat up the iron now she
asks Maggi at this point and Maggi
remember this later at the inquest
she said that Lizzie had been pointedly
asking her are you going out today are
you going out this afternoon
and then she told her that oh the
department store downstairs which is
called downtown which is called
sergeant's they're like oh they're
having this big sale it's like this
fabric that we needed it's like it's
only eight cents a yard you should go
get some blah blah blah but Bridgette
said you know it's like you know it was
really hot out she had spent all morning
washing windows she was really tired she
was still wasn't feeling very well cuz
she had a little bit the food poisoning
or whatever it was is going around she's
like you know I'm probably not gonna go
out I don't really feel all that well um
so you know so there was that whole
thing so it seemed like Lizzie was like
feeling her out like are you gonna be in
the house are you not gonna be in the
house what's going on you don't know me
now she decided some Bridgette decides
that she's kind of worn out so she is
gonna go up to her room in the attic and
she's gonna take a nap like before she
starts like making lunch or whatever
because she doesn't feel all that well
so she goes up to her room she lays down
she kind of like half dozes off or
whatever she said she did remember
hearing the clock in the town square or
whatever like striking eleven so it was
shortly after eleven o'clock after she
heard the clock she said that she heard
Lizzie shouting from the bottom of the
back stairs Maggie come down so Lizzie
immediately Maggie immediately gets up
or Bridget rather she called her Maggie
that wasn't even her name but so Bridget
gets up she puts her shoes on she runs
down there she's like what's the matter
what's the matter
Lizzie says come down quick father's
dead somebody's come in and killed him
so Bridget starts to run toward the
sitting-room which was where Andrew
Borden's body was Lizzie says to her
don't go in there go get dr. Bowen who
was their family physician he was also a
friend of the family he lived like
across the street diagonally from that
so she said go get dr. Bowen you know
he's dead you don't want to see it
so Bridget goes over to dr. Bowens house
now when she got there dr. Bowen was out
but his wife you know Bridget told the
wife mrs. Bowen that Andrew Borden was
dead and she's like you know tell him to
come over the house right away when he
gets back now as soon as Bridget gets
back because Andrew Borden had just come
in the house like half an hour before so
bridget is like well if somebody came in
and killed Andrew Borden he was just
laying on the couch it's like Lizzie was
in the house when it happened so she you
know asks Lizzie where were you when
this happened just because she was
curious now Lizzie apparently told her I
was out in the yard I heard a groan and
then I came in the screen door was wide
open
this was the screen door that had three
locks on it now it had been locked I
guess she said that she went out you
know to the barn or the yard or whatever
and then she came back the screen door
was open and her father was they did
have screens yeah they had a green door
I don't know about the windows I wonder
what the screen what a screen door
looked like back then it was it just
made out of wicker woven couldn't have
been a screen like Whedon to have today
well
well they I think they did have metal
screens because one of Lizzie Borden's
first stories was that she had gone to
the barn to find some metal or something
like that to repair a part of a screen
so maybe it had been maybe I'm wrong
maybe they didn't maybe they did have
screens maybe they did there was in the
southern houses I remember in the
windows there was no place to put
screens yeah the big tall ones like you
know well like I said I know different
this is a screen door so it was like I'm
not really sure if like windows might
have been into it oh gosh a but yes so
um yeah so they were retrofitted after
but yeah thank but well yeah I mean as
you would yeah just like I said who the
[ __ ] wants their windows open just yeah
back in the old day open for anything to
[ __ ] fly in there back in the old
days when a window was open that [ __ ]
was over you know birds flying in there
baddies went in there
yeah 1790 answers Mattoon climate in
there yeah
seventeen hundred's 1800s there's no
screens like that
which since screamed or I wonder what it
looked like in the eighth lady I don't
really know and like I said I don't know
if that screen door is still on the
house now because they've tried to
preserve the house as much as possible
from the time you know what I mean
because it's a museum and you can stay
in there now so then since dr. Brown was
not home
Lizzie sends bridgett to go and see a
friend of theirs who lived a few blocks
away whose name was Alice Russell now at
this point like the neighbors didn't
really know it was going on but
apparently they knew something was going
on because all the houses were kind of
close together everyone was kind of knew
each other in the neighborhood so they
kind of start like gathering around the
house because they're curious to see
what's going on somebody called the
police
now the next-door neighbor whose name
was Adelaide Churchill she comes over
and Lizzie's in the back door of the
house like the back entrance and she
says well what's wrong and Lizzie says
someone has killed father now this woman
because these people were apparently no
slouches they also asked where was
Lizzie when the father got killed
because they're presuming that she was
in the house which she was so they so
she asked where were you when it
happened
and Lizzie says I went to the barn to
get a piece of iron now I've heard
differing stories it's like it seemed
like she said that she was going to get
metal to like fix a screen door but then
later she said that she was going to the
barn to get some iron to make some
fishing sinkers because she was going on
a fishing trip in a few days and she
wanted to make some so that was kind of
the story that she want was later on so
she just said I'm going to get a piece
of iron so then mrs. Churchill says
where is your mother now Lizzie says I
don't know but it's like she got a note
this morning to go see a friend of hers
that was sick but then she said and I
don't know if this is a direct quote
this might be right from the trial
transcripts and this is what mrs.
Churchill said that Lizzie said to her
at the time she says I don't know that
she is killed too for I thought I heard
her come in then she said father must
have an enemy for we have all been sick
and we think the milk has been poisoned
so apparently mrs. Churchill said that
this was a
Lizzy told her shortly after Lizzy
sounds like she's trying to cast blame
on somebody else right away that's what
yeah and like I said I'll kind of get
into that I always thought she did I
kind of suspect that she did it as well
but if she did she was like really
creepily calm about it because there was
some like weird details about this that
you know that kind of suggested that I
think she was in the house talking to
people like for because the two people
like Abby and Andrew were killed an hour
and a half apart so she and she like
just did normal [ __ ] and like talk to
people like in that time span I think
she thought she had reason she probably
did like I said I don't really see again
in that minute yeah good so at this
point dr. Bowen had come back from
wherever he was so he comes to the house
now he examines the body of Andrew
Borden at this point Abby has nothing
found yet he asked for a sheet to cover
it up he determined pretty much right
away and if you've seen the crime scene
photo which is a very famous photo
Andrew Borden's face was pretty much
obliterated
that's not videos of it it was pretty
[ __ ] gruesome it's nestled just blows
over and over again around in the same
spot on his head yeah it's all in his
face um pretty much they determined
later at the autopsy that he'd been
struck with eleven blows from an ax or a
hatchet his he looks like in the picture
this is kind of [ __ ] up to say in the
picture he looks like the aliens from
they live that's what I thought just
because the the picture that they took
is just like blood and like his face is
like it doesn't look like a face anymore
because it's like space is kind of gone
it's gone um yes so it was like I said
11 blows one of his eyes had been cut
completely in half which made them
determine that it's like likely he had
been sleeping when he was attacked his
nose had been completely severed so all
is yes so all of his face was completely
obliterated like I said on one
particular he was definitely sleeping on
that couch he wasn't that photo when he
got hit he didn't know what hit him I
don't think he did because they're
pretty much they're sure that either the
first or the second blow would have
killed him
and just the killer just kept hitting to
make sure yeah of course to make sure
they were dead so could because his face
was completely smashed there was there
was blood on the you know blood on the
face obviously blood on the couch
there was there was also blood on the
wall over the sofa there was blood on
the floor there was also blood on a
picture hanging above the wall they
determined that he had been attacked
from above and behind when he was
sleeping now at this point poor Abby
Borden somebody thought hey maybe Abby
is in the house somewhere and she is
also dead so Lizzie says to Bridget I'm
almost positive I heard her coming in
why don't you go upstairs and check that
[ __ ] out yeah you know what I mean
so Bridget was like no I don't want to
do that by myself so her and mrs.
Churchill went up the stairs now mrs.
Churchill was the first person to see
because when you went up the stairs like
from the landing you could kind of see
into the bedrooms and you could see kind
of like Abby's feet like sticking out
like you know her shoes were like that
so they kind of they went up there they
saw that Abby Borden was also dead her
head was also pretty much obliterated
she was kind of laying on the other side
of the bed and they very quickly ran
back downstairs
a neighbor said is there another body
and mrs. Churchill said yes she's up
there dr. Bowen goes upstairs to examine
mrs. Borden it turned out that she had
been struck with the same hatchet or axe
19 times yeah yeah now I think there
were a lot of more from the back too
they were um they think that probably
she was like leaned over like doing
something on the bed now the bed had
been made like they said that the bed
was made really nicely like the
pillowcases were on or everything like
that because like I said about 9:30 she
had got a book full of cases to put them
on the bed and everything so that had
been done the bed was all made but she
was like laying on the other side of it
so somebody had probably just come up
behind her and just like whacked her and
just kept whacking her and then she was
like laid down laid down there now the
blood on mrs. Borden was very dark and
very
congealed and her body was kind of cold
compared to Andrew Borden's body because
they figured I mean Andrew Borden like I
said it only come home like half an hour
before the body was found
so they were speculated that Abby Borden
had been killed between an hour to 90
minutes before Andrew Borden had been
killed now oh what'd you say who live in
kit what Abby had been killed 90 minutes
before that's what I thought I okay good
90 minutes I always figured she was the
first one to be killed she was the first
one to get killed and then well that's
what's weird is there speculate that
somebody maybe Lizzie maybe not
killed Abby and then hung out for an
hour and a half until Andrew came home
and then killed him as well yeah that
could be whatever it was I thought that
she got killed first possibly why he was
asleep no he wasn't home he wasn't even
home yet no he didn't get home until a
little bit after 11:00 he was out so the
stick the stepmom was killed first
Andrew come comes in and falls asleep
upstairs without even checking he fell
asleep downstairs in the downstairs on
the cap on the sitting room okay yeah I
got it backwards but he fell asleep on
that damn couch without even checking
the house out which means that he spoke
to somebody I guarantee it was [ __ ]
Lizzie he comes in [ __ ] talks to Liz
and Lizzie doesn't act normal and
[ __ ] goes is that I I thought I liked
work you know where's your stepmom she's
like how she's asleep that's probably
what you know Lizzie told him that she
had gone out yeah he said do we know
that she said that she everybody said
that Bridget said that like several
people said that she said that and she
told other people this later on she said
I thought that she was out because she
got a note this morning that a friend of
hers was sick and she like left okay
well she said she was either asleep or
she was out but she knew that she had
already killed her stabbed mine yeah
that's what I think that's what I mean
so it seemed like a little suspicious
yeah I think she probably what she
really did she told that she was asleep
don't go there and wake her up now kept
that kept him out of that room
although like I said I think I mean
according to Bridget I guess or like the
trial transcripts they said that when
Andrew came home he did go upstairs to
the room but apparently he didn't see
anything so I don't really know like I
don't know what room he went into I
don't know if him and Abby who's ever
rooms who says this I'm just saying I
don't know it must have been Bridget
because she was the only other person in
the house
she said that he went upstairs briefly
when he came home and then came back
down and then decided to see mom's body
was in that house yeah I mean the step
the body must have been there they think
that she died about 9:30 a.m. which was
about an hour and a half before Andrew
got him like a little more than an hour
she was down on the floor kind of behind
that bed and I think that I see yeah but
I think maybe you couldn't maybe you
wouldn't be able to see her from the
door no because when mrs. Churchill and
Bridget went up the stairs to see where
Abby Borden was do this they went up on
the landing they said as soon as you
went up on the landing you could see
through the floor like they could see
her feet like sticking out from behind
her head so she was up there like she
had been up there for like an hour now
that still doesn't save Borden I think
Borden killed her well I think so too
but it's like like I said it's like I
said it's it's mostly because I don't
see how I don't really see how she could
have done it but I don't see how anyone
else could have done it either like it
seemed it seems more improbable that
someone else did it yeah that soul cop
somebody just sneaking in to kill these
two people and to leave yeah is this
possible no like I said it's improbable
I think it's more probable that Lizzie
killed I'm not saying that she did I'm
just saying that it's more probable that
she did I think she did because it would
be very very weird if it had happened
any other way very weird I think she
killed him
so apparently uh dr. Bowen he was the
one he sent a telegram to Emma who as I
said was visiting friends about in a
town about 15 miles away he also
assisted with the autopsies he gave
Lizzie a tranquilizer buzz even though
by all accounts she was not like
freaking out or anything like that she
was pretty calm but you know so he was
kind of like in the house from the very
beginning later conspiracy theories have
even like pointed the finger of blame at
him although there's not really any
motive
I'm not really gonna give that much
credence so the police were called about
11:15 a.m. now as it happened on this
particular day it was the day of the
annual picnic of the Fall River police
department so 2/3 of the police force
were having a clambake over Rocky Point
now apparently at first only one officer
named George Allen was sent to the house
now he goes to the house apparently he
sees the dead body in the front room and
then he runs back to the station house
which was only a block or two away and
tells the city marshal about what
happened so apparently there was a
half-hour gap there where after the
police arrived there were no like
authority figures other than like a
doctor or anything like that now this is
kind of a common thing and I've written
about a lot of these kind of cases you
know late 19th century early 20th
century they didn't really quite have a
handle on that whole forensic science
thing so it's like they really didn't
really seem to have any compunctions
about letting people just like run
through the houses like touch [ __ ] and
everything like that because I guess
they didn't really well it didn't hurt
printing yet yeah not really they had no
concept of DNA no of course not
they I think the best tool that they had
that time was photographs yeah and you
know just wasn't the kind of situation
where it wouldn't make a difference to
them that somebody had seen it yeah yeah
it's like I feel like they weren't
really I mean I'm not saying they were
dummies but it didn't really seem to
occur to them it's like can we not have
like all the [ __ ] neighbors and like
family members like running through the
house like looking at the body like
consoling Lizzie like you know what I
mean it's like it seems like you're just
like contaminating evidence but they
didn't really seem to that didn't really
seem like a big deal to them I don't
think it really was I don't think it was
either I don't think they haven't talked
about they didn't have the technology or
the fun right then you know the minute
or even them in the investigative
techniques that you need yeah cuz like I
said even fingerprinting at this point
was it had been used in some cases but
it was still very much in its infancy
you know what I mean and then whether or
not that were stood up in court they
were saying oh well who's to say that
people don't have the same
fingerprints yeah we don't know yeah you
know it's only the 19th century right
yeah so apparently during this 30
minutes like after the lone police
officer arrived and then like then went
back to the station house to like tell
all the other cops
apparently a County Medical Examiner
examiner named dr. Dolin happened to
walk by the house dr. Bowen who was in
the house said hey man come in here I
need your help
so dr. Dolin comes in he examines the
bodies now dr. Bowen apparently told him
this story that Lizzie had said about oh
we've all been sick and we think the
milk is poisoned
so what dr. Dolin did cuz like I said
not everyone was dummies they did like
think of some things that would occur to
people today what he did they did the
autopsy like the first autopsy just in
the house because you know that's just
what she did I guess the bodies are in
the house dr. Dolin cuts the stomachs
out of both the victims and sends them
to the Harvard Medical School for
analysis he also sent a sample of the
family's milk supply to see if it was
poisoned however no evidence of poison
was found although like I said I feel
like this all this vomiting and stuff
like that I don't think it was poison I
think it was probably food poisoning
yeah they would have known the
difference back then because they were
eating off the same leg of mutton rotten
rotten or the swordfish or whatever it
was there was a lot of things that they
ate and like I said it was very very hot
that summer you know bacteria would have
been having a [ __ ] field day yeah Roz
oh dude I'm sure that it was probably
something like that because pretty much
everyone in the house had been at least
mildly ill and you know Abby had been
violently ill and apparently Andrew had
to although he was kind of like cranky
about it the next day so so over the
next few days so the police begin an
investigation now at the first stage no
one suspected that Lizzie Borden could
be involved because you know she was a
wealthy she was a spinster yes but it's
like you know she taught Sunday school
she was a very upstanding citizen she
was from a prominent family it's like
and as I said a murder this brutal I
mean the you know
dad got 11 axe wounds the stepmom had 19
accidents this is apparently a very
violent a very brutal attack by somebody
that had a lot of rage
and at the time I think it was the
common perception that women just didn't
do that kind of [ __ ] especially kind of
like higher society women or women with
her reputation so I don't think for the
first few days after the murders I don't
think anyone really thought that Lizzie
Borden could have been responsible
everyone just kind of like took her word
for it like that things happened the way
that she said that they had happened
yeah so now and there had but there were
a couple other people that came forward
like um you know a couple of like there
was one boy that said oh I saw this mate
like a strange man like jumping over the
back fence of the Borden property they
did actually find a guy that matched
that description but he had an alibi
like he was somewhere else when the
murders occurred they also kind of
fanned out they found this bloody
hatchet at this farm in South Somerset
but later when they tested the blow it
was chicken blood
so all this other kind of stuff so like
all this kind of stuff happened but a
few days later the police couldn't help
but note that kind of the evidence was
converging on maybe Lizzie had some to
do with this stuff so what I want to do
now is I kind of want to go because this
is how the investigation went and as
they did interviews as they collected
evidence and stuff like that they think
that there were some things that
happened the day before the murders the
day of the murders the day after the
murders that kind of were circumstantial
but tended to suggest that maybe Lizzie
either did the murders or knew who did
or like was involved somehow so we're
going back to the day before the murders
which was August 3rd now there were a
few things that happened on this day
that were a little bit strange so as I
said the night before this day Andrew
and Abby had been very sick and they'd
been vomiting during the night now
Abbey had actually gone over to dr.
Bowen and said that you know everyone in
the house has been sick I think that we
have been poisoned
so Abby thought that they had been
poisoned and she went to the doctor
completely unsolicited and said that she
thought that that's why everyone was
sick now so you know he the doctor
didn't really believe it and he's like
just like you know you're fine it's
probably just nothing just go home and
deal with it however he did drop in the
next day however Andrew who was kind of
a dick and he said to the doctor he's
like hey I'm not sick and I'm not paying
for an unsolicited house call so you can
just go on your way so there was that
now another very damning apparently very
damning incident took place on August
3rd as well now apparently there was
this druggist who worked at Smith's
drugstore he was a clerk there his name
was Eli bents he told the police that
the day before the murders Lizzie had
come into the store and attempted to buy
10 cents worth of prussic acid which
that's a poison is very poisonous she
said according to him that she needed it
to kill moths on a sealskin Cape the
same sealskin Cape apparently that her
dad had bought her several years before
now he would not sell it to her because
apparently you needed a prescription for
this because it was highly boys it did
have other you know applications
obviously but you couldn't just walk in
there and buy it because it was a poison
why do you D poison to kill moths on a
cape and that's some ridiculous and some
people have said like some sources I
read said that moths are not really a
problem on popular again right yeah fir
they're not into fur right they're more
into like cotton weaves right so they
thought that was a little yeah yeah she
made that [ __ ] up so yeah now it should
be noted that even though lizzy denied
going into smith's drugstore not only
the clerk you know said that she had
tried to buy the poison but also another
customer and another clerk had
identified her because keeping mom
and that like I said this is a fairly
close-knit community um I don't think
the druggist at the time knew what her
name was but he had seen her around town
like he kind of he knew of her like he
knew she was so he would have known her
by sight so apparently the day before
the murder she had gone in and tried to
buy poison now later the prosecutor on
the case when it eventually went to
trial whose name was Hosea Knowlton he
also said that in the house he had found
like a book that was full of like
different they like herbal remedies like
recipes medicine type stuff he had found
a book in the house and that when the
book opened like it naturally opened to
the page which was about prussic acid
which seemed a little fishy
now there was also um as I said the day
before the murders the Uncle John Morris
had showed up
like I said his arrival was not all that
unusual but the fact that he had turned
up without announcing himself and that
he turned up apparently
wanting to spend the night but he didn't
bring anything with him like he didn't
have any luggage or anything like that
he just kind of turned up the way was
they thought that was a little weird now
apparently when he showed up like and
this was like corroborated with Lizzy's
testimony and with John Morse's
testimony neither of them had seen each
other before the murders which was not
weird because like I said they kind of
kept to themselves Lizzy was kind of out
he was kind of out and about and so she
had act actually not seen him on the
particular day because he had left
before she had got out now another thing
that happened and their friend Alice
Russell later testified to this fact
that the night before the murders Lizzie
had gone over to Alice Russell's house
it was her friend at the time and she
was apparently very um agitated very out
of sorts and she said to Alice Russell
that I feel as if something were hanging
over me and I cannot throw it off and
then she said something to Alice to the
effect of she thought that her dad had
enemies and that someone was going to do
something to them she specifically said
that she was afraid to go to sleep
because she thought that someone was
going to burn the house down around them
she sat in her cell
that's what it sounds like it sounds
like she's trying to set it up to like
to have an alibi
abbis have an alibi and she doesn't
really quite know what she's doing she's
not an experienced criminal so she's
trying to plant seeds and other people
and she's thinking about poisoning her
parents and she didn't get the poison
because she's taking drugs in solitary
and she's thinking about yeah and then
I'm thinking that she just blew and
decided to [ __ ] that she's like [ __ ]
it I'm just going to do this damn and
hatcheted her stepmom and she said
somebody came in here and did this yeah
that's what I've always thought but I
kind of suspect as much as well like I
said I wasn't there but it's like I kind
of suspect like all of the [ __ ] it's
like yeah they didn't really find any
physical evidence but all of this [ __ ]
that she apparently did beforehand seems
a little sketchy yeah if she was
innocent you know what I'm saying there
was a lot of societal pressure on her I
mean think about it she's not gonna get
married yeah her family life is holding
her back from being anything she's
running out of time you know yeah what
is she gonna do is she's gonna sit there
and just language languish and obscurity
you know I mean under under like the
oppression of the second kind of retro
parents yeah that are kind of like not
letting her live unless she wants to
Yeah right that's the way I'm seeing it
I kind of feel that when I'm thinking
she's like these [ __ ] have got to go
to make me free yeah because she would
get all the money yeah she'd get the
money and then in her mind you know what
I mean she's imagine in a life of travel
and men and you know what I mean or
women yes she might have been illicit
but I think she was apparently into that
yeah she she might have been to that so
you know I mean it might have been a
situation like that I can't fact that
that was because like I said that would
give her a motive I can see how I mean
she was 32 years old like I said in that
day that would have been that long an
old maid um and it is still but you said
32 you still got all those oh yeah
hormone
nowadays young yeah but she's living in
a society that's telling her that that's
now old and she's living not gonna get
married I feel like maybe if she had
been allowed to live like in society
like if they had a house on the hill if
she was allowed to like go to like all
the social functions and stuff like that
that other people of her you know social
centers or her wealth status would have
gone to then maybe she wouldn't have
been so resentful but I do feel like
there was some resentment with her
family because she felt like they were
like well we're living in this kind of
down Market neighborhood this down
Market house without all the amenities
and we're missing out on all of the
stuff that our relatives and other
people of our class are doing I mean and
I feel like she that that kind of pissed
her off I've heard the details of this
case at least five six times in my life
and I've always just come to the
conclusion that she did it and it had to
do with the fact that her [ __ ] family
life was holding her back from being a
person yeah and she blew she wanted out
of that [ __ ] somehow yeah that's the way
I remember it like I said like I said oh
you're [ __ ] telling me the case again
I'm going yeah I was right
it does seem to drive it up on her like
I said I don't think she initially
intended to kill them in the horrific or
somewhere that she did kill them I think
she would have been happier poisoning
them because it wasn't as but I feel
like because she couldn't buy the poison
and maybe she was like frustrated
because she was stymied and so she's
like well I'm gonna do this like focus
she'd already decided I mean so she just
went ahead and went with whatever she
had at hand I mean to be honest I
monsier really is a bad person well
she's clearly a bad person because she
acts two people to death but I can
understand well here's why she flipped
out here's the thing I think she was
actually a good person I think her
parents were [ __ ] [ __ ] too I
think that was a contributing factor it
doesn't mean you should kill some person
yeah but the Society of the time is that
she had no way out so there was a bunch
of [ __ ] conflicts happening yeah you
know I mean I don't imagine that you
take any modern person of today
put them in a situation you would have
[ __ ] tolerated that [ __ ] for [ __ ]
even half the amount of time she
tolerated that [ __ ] for that's true like
I said you don't limit it that way I can
understand where she's coming from like
I said it's never excusable to like acts
people to death but it but yeah that
said I can understand particularly in
that time period particularly
particularly for women because they had
much less freedom much less choices
right I can understand why a lot of
poisonings and should happen I'm showing
that I'm son I think it's right I'm not
saying I'm just saying I'm saying that
you can even put a good person in that
situation then they would and they would
blow yeah
you know I mean you know yeah I don't
[ __ ] nut see that and that's what I
think happened yeah I think she kind of
went [ __ ] nuts well clearly cuz
imagine you'd be [ __ ] hopeless and
that's a sign like I said I mean she
wouldn't she would have to wait
well she would have to wait for her
father to die now her father was 70 but
she'd also have to wait first stepmother
died because she was presuming probably
correctly that when her father died like
her stepmother would get the bulk of the
estate which was substantial which meant
that the money would all shift away from
her right yeah so I do feel like I mean
I know old was the stepmom 64 so then
you got another [ __ ] 10 20 years to
wait yeah so she's 60 by the time she's
free yeah
and what kind of life does she have yeah
I mean she was yes awesome yes she was
32 well she'd be like 53 and in that
society 5233 I mean you're over the hill
yeah as a single woman you're never
gonna have their life yeah so I'm not
putting all this on her I'm also putting
this on the situation the societal
situation that people were under back
then yeah and it was a bad time what
they were under was actually a lot worse
than guys in the [ __ ] frontier and
the Wild West
yeah back then you'd put me back on the
damn Victorian era I wouldn't be in
[ __ ] Boston man I'd be out and
[ __ ] California yeah you know what I
mean in the field doing what Tom
[ __ ] Ross does know talk about
I've had my horse which he has I can
ride I
can't even jump I can ride Western and
eggs okay his mom his mom is like a
horse trained horse trainer so I'd have
my [ __ ] horse I'd have my [ __ ] you
know a thirty to thirty [ __ ] pistol
and carbine I'd [ __ ] have money I
feel like you would probably be
perfectly happy [ __ ] right man I mean
me and [ __ ] all kinds of kruskal's
and [ __ ] the whole army of crossbow yeah
yeah I hunt down bone tomahawk style
[ __ ] you know I mean or we'd [ __ ]
hanging out with Cherokee let's go
raiding you know what's right women
would do whatever I couldn't live in New
England society well and like I said
particularly for a woman and a single
woman I'm just not wide enough I'm not
white enough to live in New England
because as 1500 ricked it as men's lives
were back then I mean where he lives
were ten times a hundred times more
restrictive than that because there was
so many things they could not do right
and if I was [ __ ] born a woman in
that era I would be a [ __ ] hooker I
think I would have been as well yeah
well like I said I read a book a while
back they had a much better life about
like some kind of famous courtesans like
in England like back in the day and I
was reading that going man their life
sounds so much better than like other
women I read it from the same era like
society women it's like I think I would
just been abroad yeah I mean if i
clunked try to become a madam yeah it
would have sucked for a while because
you had a person you'd have to like [ __ ]
a bunch of like gross dudes and that
would have sucked
um but if you could become a madam and
like own your own place
you had to own a boiler house and you
became like kind of a fashionable and
you could have liked all the artists and
poets and let your nose hang out at your
place like that was kind of what a the
demi-monde thing called an agrarian era
United States really the place to be was
in a parlor yeah okay cuz it was a world
of fantasy you had the best women the
most interesting the most interesting
people were in those photo parlors and
was kinda like the club scene you go in
your party you drink you spread the
money around spreading the wealth around
between these beautiful women and
brilliance where all the cool guys
yeah and like I said the when I read
that was what do you call it it was a
hedonistic yeah it was a hedonistic open
style that you know that's the only
place where you could be normal it was
like a more modern yes life in the midst
of life is really restricting and we're
not talking about saloons and brothels
that was yeah that middle class we're
talking about don't Tyler's we're
talking about like kind of upper class
that's the upper class yeah
because some of the like I said some of
the courtesans I read about were some of
the I made like the wealthiest like
we're wealthier than like a lot of
business owners and stuff like octoroon
[ __ ] octo and girls and [ __ ] from the
air in Louisiana those girls all had it
made in those days yeah
did they have [ __ ] sanctity religious
sanctity and honor no but they had a
different kind of otter yeah because and
like I said they had considerably more
freedom and a lot of money then and yeah
and they had their own money it's like
everyone like kind of looked askance at
them but they had a [ __ ] ton of money so
I could get around a lot of those please
plebes and normies looked askance at
them yeah but really the [ __ ] guys
who ran the society [ __ ] love them
God will never go into that that's where
they were that's where the money was
kind of on the down you talking about
governors and artists writers and
[ __ ] guys in a way that was kind of
like kind of contributed to their power
because they had dirt on air you had
hurt and they had power and incy
couldn't [ __ ] with them because it's
like for you [ __ ] with them they would
they would spill all the dirt on you
yeah you know what I mean yeah so I do
feel like and like I said I've read
several books to that effect I was just
kind of like yeah I think if I'd been
born a woman back then that was a lot of
it yeah you I would think I would be
like that's terrible to say cuz I'm sure
it wasn't great but I'm sure it was like
better than well you want to be a parlor
girl you want to be little parlor but
they call it Nikodim stars like a yeah
stars well that's where the word star is
worse that wears darker actually yeah so
you want to be a star yeah like
everybody knew who you were they were
super famous and you had all the money
you wanted and you can have it in your
own name you could own your own show
yeah and and then the whole concept of
prostitution kind of [ __ ] becomes
iffy when you're a woman that has
much money and social power and so much
status and star power that you could say
yes or no to whoever you want that's a
you could once you to a certain level
you could control your own destiny which
was and not a luxury afforded to most
women that time no you better you had to
be a player yes some of that [ __ ] oh
yeah rocks alright so as I said earlier
now on the day of the murders and some
of the statements that Lizzie gave to
police gave to other people later gave
at the inquest um we're a little
contradictory now according to the
autopsies like I said there was an hour
and a half in between the time that Abby
Borden was killed in the guest room and
Andrew Borden was killed in the on the
couch in the sitting room so whoever did
the murders would have had to kill Abby
Borden and then hung around the house
apparently for an hour and a half and
then killed Andrew when he came home so
it seemed a little like I said it's not
impossible but it seems a little
implausible that someone would have
broken into the house killed Abby Borden
and then hid in the house and keep in
mind Lizzie and Bridget were both at
home you know and somehow hid in the
house undetected for an hour and a half
and then popped out killed Andrew and
then got out of the house without anyone
seeing him or her so like I said not
impossible but very unlikely but it
leans more towards whoever killed these
people blogged in that house yeah and
like I said police came to that you're
right pretty quickly that it had to be
that it was probably someone in the
house Yeah right I must say that was
Lizzie I like I said I suspect it
probably was as well now there was also
the whole thing of like the note that
apparently arrived at the house for Abby
Borden in the morning that said Oh your
friend is sick you need to go out and
see them cuz Lizzie had told everybody
this note came and then Abby Borden left
the house now obviously Abby Borden had
not left the house because she had gone
upstairs at around 9:30 to put
pillowcases on the bed in the guest room
and had been killed very shortly
thereafter so she had obviously never
left the house
um they asked her now the police did
actually search the house for this note
obviously they didn't find it Lizzie
said oh well maybe I inadvertently
burned it because I burn a lot of
letters and stuff like that the police
even put out like a call to the public
in later days and said you know hey if
you're the person that wrote this
supposed note to Abby Borden please come
forward and say what you know and
obviously no one ever did that now that
seems very fishy although one writer did
kind of make a good point about it
they're like you know if Lizzie is
guilty which like I said I suspect that
she might have been it's like why would
she even fabricate the note when she
could have just said easily oh mrs.
Borden went out that's all she had to
say she didn't have to say oh there was
a note that came to the house which she
probably knew I mean she wasn't dumb so
just like she knew that would have been
followed up on and it's like hey where'd
this note go and all this other kind of
stuff it just would have been much
easier to say oh she went out I don't
know where she went
that would have been like the easiest
thing to do she didn't do that um so
some writers that think that Lizzie
didn't do it have pointed this out as
saying well why didn't she just say oh
she went out and left it at that instead
of coming up with this whole story about
the note which she knew would be
followed up on but you know like I said
I'm not saying that makes her innocent
I'm just saying
it seems like a weird detail so there
was um so apparently the okay so like
the weird thing about the murder was
that Andrew Borden when he came home
Bridget saw him when he came home
obviously because he couldn't get into
the house like his key got stuck or the
door was stuck or whatever so Bridget so
he had to bring the doorbell and Bridget
had to open the door
so from the time that Bridget let him
into the house and the time that Lizzie
yelled for her upstairs and said that he
was dead that was only about a half an
hour so that doesn't seem like a big
huge time you know it's not a lot of
time to act somebody to death and then
because from the way the bodies were
situated here's the weird thing from the
way the bodies were situated the person
that did this had to have been covered
in blood
pretty much yeah
um so if Lizzie had done it and like I
said I think that she did if Lizzie had
done it she killed her stepmother then
either changed dresses or hung out for
an hour and a half in a bloody dress
with no one's seeing her then killed her
father and then within a half-hour
changed into another outfit without
anyone noticing
and somehow hid the bloody dress where
no one found it because police did
search the house and apparently did not
find a bloody dress so that's another
thing that kind of makes me that's
really the only thing that makes me
question that's the only excavator II
evidence it is it just seems very she
had blood space she should have been
have blood all over her now there
must've been she must have had some way
to get rid well I'll get better aired
and she maybe she did it nude now some
people have speculated that she was
naked or that she was wearing a smock or
that she was wearing a dress over
another dress yeah but anything that has
her like wearing clothing because the
police searched the house and didn't
find any bloody clothing however it
should be noted that during this time
period it's possible that because the
police would have been reluctant to
search through a lady's personal things
that maybe she had stowed it someplace
and they didn't find it because they
thought it was improper yeah don't look
through her things true but I don't
really know but it's like I said nobody
ever found and like I said there have
been several and I think even the
Elizabeth Montgomery a TV movie I think
they I think that was a plot point of
that movie that she had like taken off
her clothes but the thing is this was
the middle of the [ __ ] day this was
like 11 o'clock in the morning it's like
would a proper Victorian woman really be
running around like in the sitting room
of her house and like the windows were
open it was like summer it was really
hot so the windows were all open or had
just been cleaned I don't think the
shades were drawn or anything like that
was she really been running around the
sitting-room naked like where other like
we're neighbors and [ __ ] could see her
well and if somebody came in it would be
much easy
or to explain it would be very hard to
explain away running around her house
naked in well I think she did plan this
well I'm sure she did I'm sure he did
plant seeds about arson yeah enemies
like I said though I don't think she
planned to ask them to death I think she
played the poison them I think maybe
when it got down to Acts and so age of
death maybe she maybe she planned it
maybe maybe she like well I'm just gonna
have to [ __ ] do this the direct way
and I kind of think she didn't take her
clothes off and thinks maybe she put
something on over him yeah some people
speculate Tom Sachs or like I said that
she had a dress over another glass and
then she did it and then she took that
off and then threw it away somehow yeah
something like that like I said I'll get
into that a little bit so like I said
there was only like a half hour so if
she did do it she cleaned up pretty
quick and like I said there was a big
gap in between the two murders so maybe
she changed clothes two times or maybe
she had a bloody dress and she put a
dress on over the bloody dress and then
took it off again I'm not really
entirely sure how she did it
um now Bridget did go outside at some
point shortly after like shortly before
Abby Borden was killed because she had
to go into the barn to get water you
know in a pail and stuff like that to
wash the window so she was out of the
house for like probably she was out in
the barn while AB newborn was being
killed but like I said when she came
back to the house everything seemed
normal and it was really weird because
after Abby Borden was killed she was
dead up there in the room
so if Lizzie had done that Lizzie was
like in the house acting normal like cuz
she was talking to Bridget and [ __ ] like
hey what are you leaving the house today
or you why don't you go down to that
sale at the department store or whatever
and she was just like ironing and doing
normal [ __ ] and Bridget didn't really
see anything strange about how she was
acting even though Abby was dead
upstairs and if she had done it then she
must have known that um so that was a
little strange too but someone acting
according to a plan can do that yeah
like I said she might have been planning
this for a very long time so it might be
and she might have been of the type of
personality that perhaps and some people
have said this about her that she was
very
cold very emotionless you know she
didn't tend to get like really upset
about anything so maybe she'd been
thinking about this for a long time and
she did it and then she was just kind of
like going about her day you know what I
mean um but like I said nobody ever
found any trace of blood on her on any
of her stuff or anything like that the
only blood they found in the house was
like at the actual scene where the
bodies were so now because of there was
also the whole thing about the burglary
quote-unquote that it happened the year
before now what had happened like I said
this house there were three locks on the
front door there were locks between all
the rooms because they were all
connected now apparently this had been
done because of the burglary that had
taken place in 1891 now in June of 1891
Andrew had called the police and said
that the house has been broken into
now his desk had been broken into and
rummaged through $100 was missing his
watch and the chain attached to it was
also missing there was a bunch of other
little things like some I think some of
Abby's jewelry and some streetcar
tickets which had been taken now the
police did an investigation at the time
however they could not find any way that
a burglar could have gotten into the
house like I said there was no they
couldn't find any sign of forced entry
they canvassed the neighborhood but no
one had apparently seen any stranger
around the house or anything like that
and like I said these houses are very
close together and everyone kind of knew
each other the police captain leader
said that Borden had told him quote I'm
afraid the police will not be able to
find the real thief some people have
speculated that Andrew Borden might have
known that Lizzie was as some have
claimed a kleptomaniac and that she had
done the robbery herself for whatever
reason and there is some like some after
the murders and after she moved away and
stuff like that she did actually have a
some some stealing later on so you know
so there there has been some speculation
that she had done now I don't know if
she was planning that far ahead because
this was like a year more than a year
before the murders I don't know if she
was planning that far ahead to make to
plant the seeds of like someone's
breaking into the house
because apparently they had also had
trouble with neighborhood boys breaking
into their barn because I think that
Lizzy caps like pigeons out there like
she had built like a little hutch for
them or something like that and I think
that neighborhood boys were breaking
into the house or they said that they
were breaking in the house and the barn
to like shoot at the pigeons cuz
apparently that was something boys did
back then so there-there was whether it
was true or not whether Lizzy was a
kleptomaniac and she had done an inside
job or not there was a perception by
Andrew Borden that he he felt like you
know kind of inundated by maybe people
are gonna break in the house or
something like that so I don't know if
he was just paranoid or because it seems
like if he knew that it was Lizzy then
he wouldn't have gone to all that
trouble to like put all these locks on
the outside doors of the house because
one thing that people like a lot of
documentaries said he held these locks
on the interior doors of the house too
but he kept the key in plain sight
almost like he was trying to send a
message to Lizzy like hey I know where
that key is so if I see that it's gone I
know it's you're up to some [ __ ] but
then he had like all those locks on the
front door too like he was afraid that
someone from outside was gonna come in
so I'm not really sure how much that but
there was a break-in
whether it was Lizzy or not they could
like I said they couldn't find any
forced entry but a bunch of [ __ ] was
stolen and was apparently never
recovered so whether Lizzy took it or
not I don't know or what that's what I
mean it's like I said this was more than
a year before the murders so if she was
planning on killing them she was
planning the [ __ ] for a long time to
like and she was kind of like a criminal
genius to like set up all this [ __ ]
[ __ ] that far ahead like in advance you
know what I mean I'm just I don't know I
don't know if I buy it or not I don't
know it's not impossible
like people have done that kind of [ __ ]
maybe what she got maybe she wasn't
planning on killing anybody by that
period but maybe setting up a robbery
was a way to put money in their pocket
yeah maybe you know you know I mean and
she could like do something with it yeah
yeah and then she said well I didn't do
that somebody else did it yeah it does
seem like a lot of her actions like I
said it's hard to say in hindsight
because we know that the mur
happened so it's like anything that she
did before that is gonna seem suspicious
but it does seem suspicious that there
was a robbery a year before that that it
doesn't that appeared was an inside job
although maybe it's possible it wasn't
and also that she said [ __ ] about like
she said she to her friend the night
before about he's good like my dad's got
enemies and I'm afraid that someone's
gonna like break in and could be this
she's just trying out her powers true
she got away with the robbery okay and
made some money on it people believe
that so maybe I believe it if I kill
these people yeah no I mean yeah like a
trial run yeah maybe that's what it was
I mean it could be it does seem very
strange that I mean it wasn't the
greatest neighborhood but I don't know
it just seems really weird and it see
the whole thing about my dad has enemies
they're gonna rob us and then it gets
robbed yeah that seems a little yeah so
on the afternoon of the murder the
police were asking Lizzie if there were
any hatchets in the house so she tells
Bridget the maid she says oh she goes
showed them where the hatchets are
because every household had a hatchet or
several because they're a very useful
tool so they found four hatchets in the
basement one had dried blood and hair on
it however this was later discovered to
be from a cow and like I said it was
dried blood it was very old one of the
other hatchets was rusted so they knew
that that wasn't it two of the other
hatchets were covered with dust however
one of these did not have a handle and
was covered with ashes now there wasn't
any blood on it than anyone could see
however because the investigators
thought that the handle had been
recently broken off this was taken into
evidence and presumed to be the murder
weapon now
who killed a [ __ ] cow with a hatchet
who knows it might not have been a cow
it might have been like a side of meat
that they were cutting on that still had
fur on it maybe see that this whole
thing in here
kind of odd if a random person breaks in
and kills two people with a hatchet and
the hatchet isn't left at the scene then
that means that that person carried a
hatchet around with him yeah I just
think that's unlikely it's more likely
they break into a house they find a
hatch in the house well everyone had a
hatchet back then that was like the
[ __ ] yeah axe man in New Orleans man
because he would just heat him bring in
an axe cuz everybody had one he just
broke in and took your ex right kill
Pitt unless you would smash people and
then just left it your finger and then
left the hatchet outside yeah that's
usually what happens yes there was
weapon of opportunity that tells me that
[ __ ] that leans more towards Lizzie
that's what I read his play catch it if
she killed him with the hatchet she
disposed of the hatchet I mean she
didn't dispose of it she left it with
the other hatchets but they thought that
it looked like the handle had been
broken off and it's possible that and
they didn't find any blood on that one
hatchet that walk and but she could have
washed it and then rubbed it in the
ashes to make it look like I kind of
think that that wasn't the hatchet it
might not have been I kind of think that
she killed him with another hatchet and
then Godwin ain't gotten rid of that
hatchet yeah and then they they went to
where the hatchets were and found
suspect hatchets and then they come try
do you guys have so many oh man you know
one of these hatchets and must be the
murder weapon
[ __ ] no yes err Alicia and if she got
rid of the damn he might have bought a
new hatchet yeah further right or
borrowed one more someone else or got
something from somewhere else like I
said I was you know so she might have
got rid of it some of the guys I really
am hatchet although like I said it's
possible that she had taken that
particular hatchet broken the handle off
and then like cleaned it and rubbed it
in ashes but she didn't have like I said
she didn't have a lot of time there was
only between the time that Andrew Borden
was killed and at the time that she
called it to Bridget that hey
Andrews dead that was only half an hour
so it doesn't really seem like enough
time because like I said there was no
running water in the house she would
have had to go out to the barn to where
the spigot was to clean the axe
then bring it back in the house go to
the I've heard basement or like room
behind the fireplace wherever it was so
she would have had to go back there like
clean it rub it in ashes and then leave
it where it would but if you've been
planning to commit this murder for a
while all right you already have a way
to get rid of that hatchet yeah they're
mighty good [ __ ] out ahead that time
there might have been a deep hole
underneath the house somewhere to where
you could take the hatchet throw it in
there and then just cover it up and they
just didn't find it
yeah or there's a place in between the
walls where you could throw it they
didn't find it you know something like
that because it seems better to just
like throw it somewhere out where no one
yeah she puts a lid on it
I mean and then like she probably
thought oh well we have a bunch of
hatchets I'll just show them those
hatchet yeah those are old she'd already
passed she had already planned all that
I mean there could have been like I said
she wasn't a dummy yeah there could have
been a place where you could throw the
hatchet behind a wall between the two
walls in the house and then those days
are no metal detectors and they weren't
gonna [ __ ] tear [ __ ] apart looking
for the damn hatchet she found a little
cubby hole where you could put it they
never found it yeah that's what I think
it could have been so that's more it's
more likely then well I broke the handle
breaking a [ __ ] hatchet handle is
hard
yeah to do and like I said she would
have had to take it out to the barn to
clean it because that's where the only
running water was and then she would
have had to bring it back to the house
and rubbed it in ashes and you're not
gonna break a hatchet handle on people
it's just not gonna happen
you know I mean I mean you can go back
to the [ __ ] Roman era for thousands
of years [ __ ] were killing
other [ __ ] and the hatchet and
acts like implements that had wooden
handles and they wouldn't [ __ ] last
hole battles yeah it's like just bashing
someone's back a few unarmored people in
the face with a damn hatchet it's not
gonna break it
yeah okay even even even a store-bought
hatchet made for chopping wood is strong
enough well because through mini heads
that's what I mean because a hatchet is
made for like cutting through firewood
and a fire firewood is abstention
harder than a human face exactly see I
with my background [ __ ] in soldierly
[ __ ] and hunters it in you know 101st
airborne stuff infantry [ __ ] I you
know I was born for anti-personnel
missions okay and and to understand how
melee weapons work even medieval weapons
okay I know that a store-bought hatchet
of the 1800s has no problem killing many
people without breaking yeah you know it
just would just will so like I said I'm
not saying that Lizzie didn't do it
we're just saying that maybe that wasn't
the murder weapon yeah that maybe they
did whatever she showed them was not the
weapon right she got rid of the weapon
that maybe she got rid of yeah oh yeah
yeah yeah well like I said if she was
planning this then if she actually did
do that robbery like a year before then
she was planning this like way ahead of
time what kind of setting up that some
well I don't think maybe she wasn't
necessarily planning on killing her
parents at that point but what she did
was she decided she was gonna steal some
[ __ ] from her parents
maybe when she got got got away with
that her confidence went up Isis knows
that she initially only planned to kill
her stepmother
yeah and then the father had to because
like I said I mean her dad was 17 he was
already pretty old it's like she didn't
really like her stepmother apparently so
I feel like she was probably just gonna
kill the stepmother and then she was
gonna like inherit good because she was
afraid that like Abby was gonna inherit
all the [ __ ] like after he died so I
think that I don't think that she was
going maybe she didn't plan to kill her
dad necessarily but she thought well
once I've killed Abby she's like well
now I have a baby with you because he's
gonna find out and right you know she
might have killed him out of panic
that's what I'm saying because he might
suspect her yeah because yet you have to
kind of like consider the human factor
yeah she may have [ __ ] got scared
after she killed her [ __ ] stepmom
yeah and then said he's gonna figure it
out
kill his ass too that's kind of what I'm
suspecting look at pokey back there like
she's like right behind your head she's
like look at Evers old look at you
hi sweetie she was she's been running
around outside all night she's asked me
to let her back out was what she does
she's not daddy okay let me back now
till later not true later you can go out
a little bit later yeah you'll be all
right
she wants to go down the back porch and
roll around in the dirt most of this
amazing [ __ ] you see in these [ __ ]
cases is actually mundane yeah it's just
that you know people that want to make
cool television programs have come in
and kind of ramped it up and brought it
look good all you gotta do is just look
at [ __ ] ancient aliens program
ancient aliens they made a whole show I
don't know nothing she's a talent yeah
Lizzie killed him Lizzie killed him
because she was under a lot of stress
she may have may have killed may have
killed the dad on the spur of the moment
but she did plan to kill a stepmom
probably I think so too I think like I
think the main intention was to kill the
stepmom and then just like to get the
estate like after her father died
because like I said I don't I don't
think that she was particularly um I
don't think there was that much
animosity between her dad other than
there may have been some resentment like
that he was kind of like cramping her
style and [ __ ] like that but I don't
think I mean her and her dad were fairly
close according to most people so I
don't think she would have oh my
goodness look at her she's not done but
I don't think she would have killed him
unless she had to I could be wrong about
that maybe she needed him to I don't
really know it was a bad situation but
yeah so um another thing that was a
little she so Lizzie's story was that on
the morning of the murder she had been
in the barn for 20 or 30 minutes looking
for iron for sinkers for a fishing trip
that she was going to in a town called
Marion she was actually going to visit
some family members in a few weeks and
she was like really into fishing so she
said that she had gone out to the barn
to get iron to make fishing sinkers now
the police thought this was unlikely
because they searched the barn and found
that vid
in there was undisturbed which suggested
that no one had been in there um also
they said look it was like over 100
degrees outside and the barn was like
really really hot and really really
stifling and they couldn't believe that
anyone would be out there for 20 to 30
minutes like voluntarily just because it
was like so [ __ ] horrible
now some people that believe that
someone else did it have pointed out
that a couple of workmen said that they
had been in the barn in a day or two
prior to the murder and also no evidence
of their presence was seen in the barn
either so that's they're kind of trying
to suggest that maybe Lizzie had been in
there and the like there was no evidence
because other people had been in there
and there wasn't a view and the evidence
of them either blah blah blah so I don't
really know but like I said her story
like kind of changed so that seemed kind
of fishy she also said that when she was
coming back from the barn initially she
said that she was outside the house and
she heard what sounded like her father
quote-unquote groaning but in another
version of the story she said she heard
a scraping noise like coming from inside
the house which like alerted her that
something bad was going on inside the
house as she went inside because she had
been out in the barn so she claimed that
she had been outside conveniently for
the 20 to 30 minutes in which Andrew
Borden had been killed which again seems
a little too convenient now there was
another inconsistency now during the
inquest and statement she had given
before the inquest because as we will
note when we talk about the trial she
actually did not testify at the trial
however there was an inquest before that
where which was kind of like a trial
where they had the prosecution and
defense and everything like that
she actually said at this inquest there
were two different versions of the story
she said that when Andrew Borden got
home that she had come down and she had
either seen him take his shoes off or
because he didn't feel well and was
gonna laid on the couch for a nap that
she had helped him out of his shoes and
into his slippers however when his body
was found he had his regular street
shoes on he didn't have slippers on so
that was another inconsistency so when
one of the deputy marshals whose name
was John fleet
question Lizzie he asked her initially
who do you think might have committed
these murders like who do you think
wanted your father dead now she said
that there was this man whom she didn't
know what his name was and it's like Oh
him and my dad like had this argument a
couple weeks before but I can't think of
anyone else however later on she
actually um pointed the finger at her
uncle Hiram si Harrington now she later
said this is the only person that I
could think of that would want Andrew
Borden dead
however she only said this after Hiram
si Harrington went on record as saying I
don't think he came right out and said
that Lizzie had done it but he thought
it was someone in the house and implied
that he thought it was probably Lizzie
so it seemed like it was her getting
back at him for like pointing the finger
at maybe he was the one that did it um
they did ask her if either john morse
who the uncle who was staying with them
or bridget the maid who was the only
other person in the house at the time
could have killed Andrew Borden she said
that neither of them could have it does
seem like there are some theories that
say that john moores could have done it
but it seems unlikely because he left
the house very early in the morning uh
probably more than an hour before Abby
was killed he left before 8:00 in the
morning and several people saw him he
was only going a mile away like to
relatives houses but several people saw
him on street cars and like at various
places in there so they're imagining
that probably he didn't do it
um another thing that people thought was
suspicious was that when fleet
questioned her he specifically asked
well who do you think could have caught
it could have killed your father and
mother she specifically stepped up and
said she's not my mother she's my
stepmother my mother died when I was a
child so they thought that was a little
vision so August 5th which was a couple
of days after the murder investigation
continues stories started appearing in
the newspaper of course is a very big
deal the whole town is like flipping out
this is a very prominent family
you know so this was the same day that
Eli bents the guy from the drug store
came forward and talked about the prusik
acid and stuff like that now August 6th
was the day of Abby and Andrews funeral
the surface was conducted by two
Reverend Reverend buck and Reverend Judd
who were actually friends of Lizzy she
worked for them like I said she was you
know very high up in that church and
they were both her constant defenders
they appeared with her in court several
times weirdly though they have the
funeral but they're going to bury the
bodies and the police came and said yeah
you can't bury them because we're gonna
do another autopsy so they took the
heads off the pot hey Stan they took all
the skin off what and they made plaster
casts of their skulls how does that help
with this somebody trying to make some
money so apparently like poor Andrew
Borden's head was not returned to the
coffin I think it was buried separately
later on or later was like thrown in the
coffin of nerely sure on the same day a
newspaper ad appeared which had been
paid for by Lizzie and her older sister
Emma offering a $5,000 reward for
information leading to the arrest and
conviction of the person who had
murdered their parents so there you go
now August 7th this was a Sunday morning
Lizzie's friend Alice Russell came
forward and told the police on Sunday
morning I saw Lizzie burning a dress in
the kitchen stove now the weird thing
about this was that when Lizzie was
burning this dress not only was Alice in
the kitchen but her sister Emma was also
in the kitchen she was doing the dishes
because the maid Bridget had [ __ ] off
she's like I'm not she quit shows Friday
or Saturday like prior to this like a
couple days after the murders she got
all her [ __ ] and got out so so Emma was
in there doing housework Elsa and for
some reason like Lizzie is in there
burning a dress so Alice says to her
she's like that looks a little
suspicious like if I were you I wouldn't
let anyone seeing you doing that
at which point Lizzie said oh this is an
old dress and it had paint on it so I'm
getting rid of
because it's not of any use to me
anymore
so they had trash collection back then
that seemed yeah that seemed a little
weird now I will say that it's like okay
now if Lizzie had done it which like I
said I suspect that she did it seems
weird that one she didn't get rid of the
dress that she wore before this like
what because this was four days after
the murder why didn't she get rid of it
when no one was looking at her because
not only was her sister in the kitchen
her friend was in the kitchen while she
was burning the stove but there was also
a cop outside the house who'd been
stationed like watched the house he was
that he was supposed to watch them and
like keep all the onlookers like away
from like from running around in the
house on the property so it seemed weird
if she was gonna get rid of the house
unless she was like trying to do like a
hide in plain sight type of thing maybe
that's what she was going for I'm not
really sure but you know neither her
sister nor the friend said that they saw
any blood on the dress they just said
that she was burning it in the stove and
that seemed a little strange now this
was the testimony of Alice Russell who
said that she'd seen her burning the
dress in the stove that actually led to
Lizzie Borden being arrested and charged
with the murders prior to this like I
said they had kind of suspected that she
was in it but there wasn't like a lot of
evidence for it but when Alice Russell
came forward and said look I saw her
burning a dress four days after the
murders and that seemed a little
suspicious to me that seemed like the
main thing that they were getting is
because like I said they had found no
bloody dress during the search of the
house they had found her like I said so
she might have been wearing one but I
don't know where the dress was in the
four days and why she didn't get rid of
it before that if India was a bloody
dress the ground was it the cops were
right to arrest her after that
yeah because how many times have you
burned a dress never right you just
throw that [ __ ] away my friend runs him
away yeah not because they had blood on
yeah yeah yeah like I said it seemed a
little fishy and but like I said in in
her defense you'd think that if she'd
really done it she would have waited
until she was alone to do that [ __ ] so
no one would have seen it
to reward to the cops but like I said
maybe she was doing some like reverse
psychology lever suspect I'm gonna do it
right in front of I'm gonna do it right
in front of him it's like that won't be
suspicious anymore I got paint on this
[ __ ] yeah more blood yes little red
specks of paint how was painting a fence
and I just got it yes so this was at
this point that they arrested her for it
so as I said there was a lot of
testimony the inquest and the inquest
was kind of like unusual in
jurisprudence history because it was
almost like a trial even though there
was no jury present like there was like
the prosecution the defense and
everything like which was very strange
um but that's kind of how they did it
when the trial actually commenced I mean
because the defense team was kind of
hoping that at the inquest like enough
evidence would come out that Lizzie
wouldn't get charged and the whole thing
would blow over but that's kind of not
how it happened
particularly the testimony by Alice
Russell like saying about the burning of
the dress and everything like that so
the judge kind of thought that there was
enough evidence to go to trial for the
murders now as I said before I can't
murder if I said it before but Lizzie
was actually charged for this is very
weird but she was charged with three
murders she was charged with the murder
of Abby Borden the partner of Andrew
Borden and the murder of both of them
what right so I I don't know why they
did that seem like a very her insane to
single burg
yes every murder that was three charges
of murder right which as far as I know I
don't know if that's been done before
but that was like a very unusual so a
lot of people have commented on it so um
so she didn't actually go to the trial
because the judge thought that she was
probably guilty quote/unquote um she
testified at length at the inquest or
the hearing or whatever however when the
trial came along she did not testify at
all pretty much all she said was to
stand up and say I'm innocent I will let
my counsel speak for me that's all she
said at the trial now evidently at the
trial which lasted 14 days which was a
very long time for that time period and
like I said it was a huge deal like in
the media and everything
every day like they were coming out with
it was like you know reporters from like
all over the [ __ ] country like
sitting in on this [ __ ] but um
apparently on the advice of her lawyers
she had actually really good lawyers she
had the family lawyer and she had like
another one that was you know the family
because she had a lot of money so they
could pay for it so it was kind of like
they advised her to wear black they're
tasteful and so she was in mourning also
she acted kind of like you would expect
you know kind of in a 32 year old
spinster of society woman to act at a
trial there was one point in the trial
where one of the attorneys was like
trying to be dramatic and he like threw
that one of the dress that she gave to
the police which was probably not the
dress that she had committed the murders
in if indeed she committed them because
it was silk and the dress that she had
been wearing was made of corduroy but he
threw it on the table
and there was he had the skulls of a bee
and reporting which were to be brought
into evidence later but he had like
tissue paper over them so when he threw
the dress it like blew the tissue paper
off so the skulls were visible and
Lizzie very sorry the kitties cats
[ __ ] with the camera stop [ __ ]
she's loving on the cam I know she's
like I'd so painted to me what she's
doing just imagine pookie like tripod
alone okay she loves it
but yeah so the tissue paper blew up the
skulls and Lizzie perhaps in an act of
theatricality perhaps it was natural I
don't really know but she supposedly
fainted dead away now this was like I
said this might have been on the advice
of her lawyers because they did say hey
show up in court like be very demure
like where your morning clothes
act like a person thing was all fake and
you know it's like kind of like you know
swoon at certain times because that's
what ladies were supposed to do when
something you know terrible or shocking
happens yours beau I just can't deal
with it you know I mean so she did that
kind of [ __ ] now as I said the trial
lasted 14 days the jury deliberated for
less than an hour and came back with a
verdict of not guilty now the
interesting thing was
that like I said she had a lot of
supporters um the all the people at the
church then she worked for the Reverend
and everything like that well they were
just convinced that she could not have
done it there was just no way um a lot
of uh you know women's groups like
women's rights groups like took up her
cause a lot of women's rights groups
kind of used her case to argue for
certain things that they were arguing
for like because at that time women were
not allowed to serve on juries so they
and her jury was indeed all men so they
thought that it would be more fair if
she had had women on the jury because
jury of her peers and whatever so they
kind of used that in their causes so
there was like a lot of political
machination is going on behind the
scenes
I should it should be noted too that
just as in modern times the media like
when there wasn't any like compelling
news about the story you know about the
case they would make up some [ __ ] and in
case one case one newspaper I can't more
which one it was but they pretty much
made up I believe it was twelve
different witnesses they made up their
names like where they were from and
everything like um had been and in the
neighborhood like when the neighbor when
the murders occurred it's like Oh some
of them said that they had seen you know
Lizzie through the windows it's like oh
one of them like overheard Lizzie like
arguing with her father about her being
pregnant by some boyfriend and like that
was and he was like you know you'll I'll
cut you out of the will or some other
kind of [ __ ] famous fake news so there
was all kind of that [ __ ] going on and
then there were other stories about like
other people that I say was there was
like a wild man that was running around
like somebody saw like some dude sitting
on a wall with a bloody hatchet waving
it at people and [ __ ] like that yeah it
was all kind of that [ __ ] they had
newspapers they had to sell that's what
is so it's so like I said if anybody
thinks that like nowadays it's like yeah
I in a way it was like for his worse
from everything I've read it was way
worse than because they had like no
compunctions whatsoever about just
pulling [ __ ] right under their ass just
like making a fictional story just
printing it just because there was
really only good really
I'm accountable so he just did it that's
what I mean it's like there was nothing
you would do about it really freedom of
the press in the United States which
meant you could lie yeah
which they did and apparently like I
said in this case at least one newspaper
straight up invented about 12 witnesses
like I said gave him names like
realistic sounding addresses everything
that were conveniently in other cities
that like people couldn't check and it's
funny how you have network news stations
today trying to shut down youtubers
because if they're lying
that's what that's what they're saying
that [ __ ] was all fake news it didn't
matter
it didn't matter like I said that like I
said I don't even think back then they
had much of a concept now they were just
trying sell papers yeah trying to sell
futures like I think it's worse back
then because I'm trying to get hit
because I don't think they had any
concept of well you know that's not
really at least nowadays if you print
something that's not true like a lot of
people will come out and be like hey bro
what the [ __ ] but it's like back then I
don't really think anybody cared about
that kind of [ __ ] because that was just
like what people did you just just let
the buyer beware back then pretty much
yeah yeah so I think they were hip to it
though well a lot of but there were a
lot of like legends that came of Lizzie
Borden too so that like I said that's
why it's hard to kind of come to a
conclusion about a case that happened so
long ago because you don't even know
like even if you read like newspapers at
the time you don't know how much of that
[ __ ] well I look at damn heirship
stories from those days yeah and it's
obvious that they were written in a way
to where the audience was supposed to be
in on it yeah and that they knew that it
was that heirship stories were fake well
yeah they did a lot of them and we don't
know about that before but like I feel
like that like I said the context was
different and I think there were there
was a certain genre of stories back then
that were supposed to be like a found
footage of like what we call nowadays
yeah um that we're supposed to be like
oh it's real but everybody like knew
that it wasn't real think of a world
that didn't really have entertainment
you had to get her into entertainment
somehow so the newspapers were
delivering a four
these kids were pushing hoops through
the street with a stick yeah that's the
entertainment that yeah it was that kind
of [ __ ] so as I said it took less than
an hour for the jury to exonerate Lizzie
Borden she was found not guilty not
enough evidence to convict her now
Lizzie and Emma her older sister ended
up receiving the bulk of their father's
estate which was in those days money was
$300,000 in today's money was well over
8 million yeah that's a lot of money it
was a lot of money so um because like I
said now the stepmother would have got
it next but she was dead too so they
ended up so it kind of falls into the
into the old meme of or the old [ __ ]
you know story of getting the
inheritance and you know when you're
talking about the eighteen hundred's in
the United States a lot of [ __ ]
were killed over that damn and I that's
why I feel like it's probably this seems
like it's one of those cases I think so
too because apparently there had been a
lot of resentment about because they had
the money the family had the money yeah
but they weren't living in the way that
other wealthy people at the time we're
living even Walt Disney knew about this
back in the 1800s I got to do is just go
to the goddamn Haunted Mansion yeah
being behind the Haunted Mansion is
about women killing husbands for the
inheritance yeah yeah
I definitely feel like that was probably
thinking that was just the way what they
did back this so yes so Lizzie and Emma
got over eight million dollars after
about five weeks after the Trenton now
about five weeks after the trial ended
and Lizzie was found innocent or found
not guilty rather um
Lizzie actually ended up later changing
her name slightly to Lizbeth a Borden um
it should be noted that she was not born
Elizabeth she was actually Christian
christened Lizzie so that was her name
she wasn't named Elizabeth and that was
a nickname she was actually made Lizzie
but she changed her name to Lizbeth
Borden later on five weeks after the
trial she and Emma bought a house
thirteen rooms it was a stone mansion at
3:06 French Street in Fall River now
people have speculated it's like why
Lizzy live in Fall River because so many
people it's weird because there was a
lot of people that supported her during
the trial and thought she was innocent
however after she was acquitted and she
decided to stay in Fall River
Massachusetts she was essentially
ostracized she would go to church and
everyone would move the pews and there'd
be like this big gap around her yeah she
couldn't really go out without people
you know like just moving away from her
so she was like a pariah
she had cooties yeah essentially she had
murderer cooties yeah now um but this
house that they bought in Fall River
finally have they used their daddy's
money to buy a house on the hill the
fashionable neighborhood where they had
always wanted to live the house is
called Lizzy decided to call the house
Maplecroft and she had that carved into
the front step of the front house that
house is still there there are still
pictures of it it's actually it didn't
look that great outside it's actually
got eight bedrooms it's less than 4,000
square feet which is very small for a
mansion which is what they call it but
the inside of it is [ __ ] gorgeous it
recently sold on the open market
I believe it sold for about $700,000 but
like I said the outside doesn't look all
that great it's not a mansion by today's
standards but the inside is really
beautiful it looks like [ __ ] from back
then like it looks like it's been
completely done out the way it would
have looked back wooden floors and their
honors and every yeah it's really
beautiful and it's it's like all done
out so it looks like a museum inside but
apparently as far as I know like last I
heard it had been sold it was actually
on the market for 800,000 but I think
they had to drop the price because there
wasn't a lot of I mean no one was
murdered in the house as far as I know
but Lizzy had lived there like in the
last part of her life and you would
think that somebody would pay a lot for
that kind of like historical notoriety
but apparently not it said they had to
drop one hundred thousand but somebody
bought it recently now interestingly
like I said shortly after and over her
and Emma lived in this house in 1897 now
as I was saying before about this
robbery this mysterious robbery that
happened at the boarding house in 1891
in 1897 five years after the murders
Lizzie was charged with the theft of two
paintings
that she had stolen from the Tilden
Thurber store in Fall River she had
apparently stolen these paintings from
this store and then given them as gifts
to other people
she you know she she sounds like this is
like a sociopath yeah well some people
have speculated that she was maybe a
kleptomaniac at the very place yeah but
that's part of sociopath II says yeah
I'm drunk I can't I can't
you can't hurt a guy can't articulate
what I'm drunk what is she got taught
because one of the paintings that she
gave is a gift to somebody else like I
guess the frame broke or something and
the woman brought it back to the same
store I like to have the frame fixed and
they were like hey this was stolen from
her store back so then they've like
remembered and so she apparently she
wasn't charged with it apparently like
she paid off everybody like it was
settled like outside of the courts or
whatever but so that's like another kind
of evidence that she was not exactly
like the upstanding citizen that
everyone believed now in 1904 Lizzie
apparently met this actress named Nancy
O'Neil now for the next two years after
that Lucy and Nance were together pretty
much all the time and Nance was a very
common fixture at Maplecroft the house
that she shared with Emma um and at one
point I believe she gave like a
week-long house party for this one now
Nance O'Neil apparently became even when
like motion pictures started like silent
movies started becoming popular she was
apparently uh became quite popular in
that mostly in like tragic roles I found
like tons of pictures of her so she was
apparently quite famous um so she has
this big party for them there was rumors
that her and Nance were romantically
involved I don't know if that's true or
not but she did seem to have like an
obsession with her she often went to
other cities to see her in stage
performances and various other things
now apparently it was this that caused a
rift between Lizzie and her sister Emma
who apparently couldn't quite [ __ ]
take it anymore so Emma moved to Fair
Haven and apparently her and Lizzie
never spoke ever again even though they
been very close after the murder and
Emma had apparently supported Lizzi all
during the trial and you know like I
said they bought a house together like
after the trial and stuff like that so I
don't know if Emma thought that Lizzi
was not guilty or if they had conspired
together on the murder which may have
been possible although like I said Emma
was out of town when the murder occurred
but Emma apparently did not believe that
Lizzi had done the murder or like I said
they were working together so they were
actually kind of together but this whole
thing with the actress was apparently
the last straw so Emma [ __ ] off she
moved somewhere else and they never
spoke again
Emma moved too she stayed with Reverend
buck for a while who would been another
one of Lizzi supporters and then a 19-15
Shemer moved to New Hampshire
Lizzie ended up dying in 1927 at the age
of 67
she had gallbladder surgery and then had
like a lot of illnesses after that her
sister Emma mysteriously died only a
little more than a week later I've heard
that she died either from falling down
the stairs at her house or because she
had nephritis now the two of them were
buried together in the family plot so
they were buried they were buried like
right where the parents were buried
their sister and everything like that so
andrew borden who apparently still
didn't have a head and everything like
that
so all of the money that was left when
they died
Lizzie ended up leaving $30,000 in those
days money to the Animal Rescue League a
fall river because she was apparently a
big animal lover this is kind of
contradictory to a lot of legends that
circulated about her later that said
that she had once decapitated a kitten
that in the cellar of the old house like
it was Andrew Borden's kitten or
something like that I feel like I kind
of feel like that's probably unlikely
and everyone that knew her in later life
said that she [ __ ] loved animals and
she would never she had horses like she
built you know boxes for the squirrels
and stuff like that it's like this she
never would have done such a thing I
don't know where that legend came from
but you know what I mean so she gave a
large bulk of the estate when she died
to the
rescue league she also left $500 in
those days money for the care of her
father's grave the remainder of it was
left to friends family and servants Emma
also left a substantial sum to both the
Boy Scouts and the Girl Scouts now
Bridget Sullivan the maid who some
people have suspected may have played a
part in the murder in in the sense that
maybe there have been there's been some
speculation that Lizzie and Bridget were
having an affair
or that Bridget knew that Lizzie had
committed the murders and somehow it
covered up for her you know so but there
were like think because the thing about
it is that when Abby was killed when
Abby Borden was killed she was killed
much earlier than Andrew Borden when she
was axed in the upper floor when she hit
the floor this was a 200-pound woman so
when she hit the floor you'd think that
Bridget the maid the only other person
in the house would have heard something
and gone up there to investigate so some
people have speculated that Bridget may
have known what was going on and covered
up for Lizzie later on I don't know if
that's true or not I say no however yes
so it's like a lot of people have said
to it's like oh she got this big payoff
and she went to Ireland like and all
that other kind of stuff but you know
the evidence shows that that was not the
case the evidence shows that she
actually ended up going to the Butte
Montana and works for a family there she
did not have a ton of money she did not
go back to Ireland or anything like that
so I don't think though that she knew
what was going on or anything I think
Lizzie ran up on her stepmom while she
was making the bed or something she was
kind of in a lower position and what it
lacked her right in the back of the head
started beating her to death she didn't
have very far to fall I don't think it
made much of noise this is all you know
I mean this is all good people trying to
be Sherlock Holmes trying to piece
together a crime scene difficult to
predict how people react different
things you know it's very difficult to
know how you know where someone was at a
certain time and how the Adamic tack
went down
I think I think Lizzie stepmom what's up
by the side of the bed me making the bed
and then Lizzie ran up maybe with some
kind of a sheet over her or something or
in some kind of [ __ ] clothing to
protect her main clothing or maybe like
a dress that she burned later something
like that
then threatened her stepmom with an act
with a hatchet and her mom and her
stepmom cringed and she just started
whaling on her yeah I own I think it
made that much noise I honestly think
she snuck up on her because Leo loves it
I think as far as I remember all of the
wounds were in the back of her head yeah
which means she snuck up on her
yeah so it probably didn't that probably
didn't make much noise and if I didn't
take very long and then she she killed
she killed her stepmom and then she's
sitting there going oh [ __ ] I'm gonna
get caught
yeah dad comes in and goes where's your
mom where's your step a lot or no she
died she had a message and he's talking
to her he goes up and falls asleep on
that damn couch she starts thinking
about and she's like he's gonna I can't
hide this body you know I'm in big
[ __ ] [ __ ] well how am I to get out of
this well I gotta kill this dude you
know I mean yeah like I said I don't
even know if she initially wanted to
kill her dad but I won't think once what
happened yeah I feel like she thought
she didn't have any and it may be that
she was kind of planning on killing him
but she wasn't really gonna do it
she was just famous she was kind of
fantasizing about up certain plan and
maybe on that particular day she got
into an argument where stepmom and I
just thought well T like I'm gonna kill
that [ __ ]
yeah because maybe she didn't even
intend to kill them that day well it's
like I said if the druggist and a couple
other people in the drugstore are to be
believed she was she was thinking about
poisoning them because she did actually
try it unless she was buying it for some
innocent purpose which I don't really
believe but you know so she was probably
like oh I'm just gonna poison them and
make it look like because like I said
everyone had had food poisoning that had
been sick so she could have just
attributed to that her hatred for them
was building up she was fantasizing
about it thinking about it and had all
different kind of ideas of
and on that particular day that stepmom
said something to her and she said I'm
gonna kill this [ __ ] yeah and she just
went up there and then she went up and
got the axe and then it says I'm gonna
do it now and ran in on her and [ __ ]
got her and then went oh [ __ ] damn this
is so this is the real deal I killed her
then dad shows up she talks her way into
that out of that a little bit he goes to
sleep up on top of you and she's like
well I guess I got to kill him well
because it does seem like I mean this is
a classic case of what police
investigators would call overkill
because it seems like the first or
second hatchet blow would have killed
either one of the victims and the fact
that she just kept going that suggests
to me that this was someone that hated
them and they just after she knew they
were dead she just kept on yeah well she
had been hating on him for [ __ ] years
yeah and it was building up I feel like
no one else hated them enough to do that
to them well there's nothing it's
impossible because it does happen but as
you saw him his [ __ ] they were
holding her back and you know I mean
treating her bad and that's what I think
yeah she now be who she wanted to be
yeah we're in the way so like I said
even though I kind of like you know I I
lean toward the you know the theory that
Lizzie did it because I don't really see
how any was like I said there have been
like a lot of other theories not all of
them like exonerating Lizzie entirely
some of them say that her sister Emma
did it and that there was like this the
whole thing of her going to Fair Haven
to visit relatives that was just like a
cover story and that she came back and
did it and then she went back and then
they knew that Lizzie wouldn't get
convicted because she was a woman of
blah-dee-blah so they had planned it
together which you know that's maybe
possible because Emma had the same
grievances I guess it Lizzie had some
people like I said have suspected that
Lizzie and Bridget were having an affair
and that someone that Abby found out
about it and was gonna narc on her and
so it's like you know that whole thing
happened and then the like Bridget
covered up for there's also been another
theory circulating the
there was another previously undisclosed
player in this whole situation who was
apparently the illegitimate son of
Andrew Borden whose name was William
Borden who was apparently they call him
[ __ ] I don't know if he was like
actual [ __ ] [ __ ] or like I don't
really know but some people have said
that he had an illegitimate son and he
was the one that did it because he was
getting written out of the will
and that then sounds very like like yeah
and that like Lizzie and Emma were like
well we can't let you know him come to
light because then we won't get the
money and like all this other because so
they knew about it so that seems like a
stretch that's [ __ ] I'm not even
sure that that dude exists yeah we have
to say he would been documented at the
scene he would have been in there all
the time and you know I mean the
witnesses would have been talking about
him that's something so amazing that's
what I mean I think that was kind of
like a later extrapolation because like
I said I'm not even entirely sure Lizzie
did this the stories go that like Oh
William like committed suicide a few
years later like oh he was guilty about
stuff but it's like like I said I'm not
really entirely sure that that dude even
existed Lizzie did that [ __ ] I kind of
am leaning toward because yes there are
a lot of inconsistencies like where did
the bloody dress go it's like how did
she kill somebody in like such a short
time and like be calm and like what she
wasn't coming to buy stuff like that uh
but the investigators of the time
weren't up to the task and that's it you
gotta understand that it's that easy
back in those days to get rid of a dress
or a murder weapon and like I said I
feel like they would have retinol they
didn't have a [ __ ] a [ __ ] good
investigative technique they just did
limit all that luminol didn't have
aluminum like I said I don't think it
would have one I don't think they would
have gone through a lady's personal
things yeah and some people have pointed
out that it's like if she had one dress
on over another dress yeah um they're
like probably the police would not have
thought to been like hey take off that
dress see you have a like to check for a
dress underneath so it might have been
that her dress was covered in blood but
she put another one on over it and they
didn't think to like look underneath you
know what I mean which that could have
been too and
like I said it does seem weird to me
that if she had done it and if the dress
was covered in blood which it probably
would have been it's like she should
have probably destroyed it before that
like when no one else was around but
maybe like you you know maybe like we
said she was thinking well I should do
it in front of other people so it won't
look as suspicious yeah because it won't
look like I'm hiding something right so
maybe that's what her thinking was but
at any rate like I said she was
acquitted of the murder so the murders
are actually officially unsolved and she
did go on to have I mean she was
ostracized but she had a lot of money
she got into the theater later on she
spent a lot of time and you know big
bigger cities Boston Washington DC and
stuff like that because she said she
liked going there because no one knew
she was really they didn't recognize her
so she could spend a lot of time there
and not have people like ostracizing her
um but I I don't know she had a very
happy life after that you know what I
mean by happier than what she had
although yeah I mean she did have money
she had freedom all right yes after a
while she was hanging out with that
actress and Laura I was hanging out in
that scene so maybe she was like yeah
yeah I think it did get better and some
people that knew her in later life and
actually it's weird because one of the
documentaries I saw which was you know
fairly old but there was a woman on
there he was old enough to have known
Lizzie like when Lizzie was an old woman
um and she said that she didn't really
believe that Lizzie could have done it
because she seemed like a really nice
person but that does whatever we mean
anything because like I said a lot of
serial killers like Ross they always
seem so nice so we never would have
suspect was another era back in then and
I do feel like she I feel like she was
smart enough to know that at the time
people would not have suspected a woman
of her class and station to have done
such a brutal crime and I think she
played that to her advantage like I said
I don't think she was dumb no like I
said it's unusual it's very unusual for
a woman to kill people with an axe or
hatchet usually like I said they will
use less ostentatious methods Ang Lee's
poison where firearms or something
easier much like you know yeah but she
knew that too but I do feel like
probably she did it and then used her
station and yet I got it - yeah make it
look like you know she was a big thing
in the church and everything like that
so I think she used that to her
advantage so like I said I don't think
she was stupid she did that [ __ ] I kind
of feel like she probably did too but
you know all right so we have gone on
wait long wait I expected because of Tom
and his drunken die grant we're gonna
put it on me
I'm not sending to you and reacting to
it but now it was a good shows it was I
thought it was very good even that we it
took us a while like isn't it but you
know what I mean so this was our episode
of Lizzie Borden case hopefully you guys
enjoyed this rambling discussion as we
always do and remember if you like the
show please like share subscribe with
all your friends and family please share
on all your social media and all that
whatnot if you would like to financially
support the show be much appreciated you
can go to our patreon page
patreon.com/lenguin
there's a button in the sidebar to a
PayPal account if you would like to give
a one-time donation it would also be
much appreciated and this has been a
hundred I've said 176 I'm not that drunk
176 176 isn't that crazy Christ I know
we've been going on a very long time
yeah we'll see you next time bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]